e
a public Hearing in C Bill 173 and Grant
are you going going to introduce the
bill
okay holy moly look at the amended
bill good morning chairman hunt members
of the Commerce Committee uh my name is
Grant bossy Deputy Chief of Staff of the
New Hampshire Senate introducing Senate
Bill
173 on behalf of Senator Sharon Carson
the Bill's Prime sponsor this bill
brings New Hampshire law into line with
the Federal no surprises act uh
providing consumer protections to New
Hampshire patients at a vulnerable time
this bill provides the department of
insurance with authority to resolve
disputes it expands New Hampshire's
surprise billing statutes to align with
federal law it establishes rules to
improve price transparency for healthc
care services and it expands the
patients Bill of Rights to provide
patients with notification of their
rights I will defer technical questions
to the department and other experts here
today but if you have any questions
questions for Senator Carson I can get
them to her and ensure you get an answer
Senator Carson thanks you for your
consideration and support of Senate Bill
173 thank
you okay thank
you I assume no one has any
[Laughter]
questions okay so uh insurance
that's the written
test
yes good morning chairman hunt members
of the committee for the record my name
is DJ beton court and I have the
pleasure of serving as the commissioner
of the New Hampshire insurance
department I'm joined this morning by my
colleague Alex Feld Daval Senate Bill
173 represents a three-year effort of
the New Hampshire insurance department
to synchronize state law with the
federal no surprise act and to accept a
healthy amount of delegated authority
that the federal government has made
available to the states to enforce the
provisions of the no surprises act the
reason that this has taken as long as it
has is because there's a lot that is
included here and we have had to work
very carefully and I think very
constructively with a number of
different stakeholders and at this point
we have found a compromise between
carriers and providers and obviously the
Department itself is satisfied that we
now have the ability to provide as much
consumer protection as we are able to
given the Contours of the no surprises
act so in short not to be repetitive of
what Mr bossy said this bill will
harmonize New Hampshire's existing
balance billing law with the federal law
so that we will have one standard one
set of standards and protections and not
two as currently exists we have
protections for a more narrow
limited set of practices in state law no
surprises Act is more expansive we want
to Simply match the protections that the
federal government has made
available uh just as in the no surprises
act it requires Health carriers to cover
the relevant out of network services in
the same manner as if the services were
provided by an in network provider or
facility most importantly the bill
establishes a state level independent
dispute resolution process C to resolve
disputes about the fair value of Medical
Services provided by outof Network
providers and I want to stop here for uh
two important points for your
consideration the first is the way
current statute is in New Hampshire when
there is a dispute and you're trying to
determine what that fair market value is
the process is such that the parties can
appeal to the department and the
commissioner whoever he or she may be
serves as the oneperson IDE r that was
the nature of the compromise that was
reached in
2018 we have since had conversations
with both providers and carriers who are
a bit uneasy about having one individual
have that type of authority so what
we've done instead is kind of tried to
create a Choose Your Own Adventure story
for the parties uh they can go the
independent dispute resolution process
at the federal level or they can have
the same type of process at the state
level and what that looks like is the
federal government has contracted with
independent idrs they take in the
complaint they send it off to the IDR
the IDR makes a determination and that
determination is binding on the parties
we would do the exact same thing here in
New Hampshire with a couple of different
improvements the first is our system
will not break down like the federal
government system has it's frequently
subject to litigation and therefore
shuts down uh the federal process has at
times been overwhelmed and so therefore
or they have to shut down to allow for
themselves to catch up and we will do it
faster and cheaper we have heard
unfortunately of instances where the
carrier has lost the arbitration through
that IDR process and has been very very
slow to pay the provider what was agreed
upon we obviously will make sure that
does not happen here in New Hampshire so
as I've said we've worked really hard
over a number of years to come up with a
good compromise uh we are here and so we
hope obviously the committee will take
this under consideration and move it on
to the governor thank you Mr
chairman okay we have questions
representative burrow just a second you
next is it me or him yeah okay uh thanks
for taking my question if the state
level uh arbitration is is chosen is it
still just go before you as an
individual no what we will do as I said
is we will the department will take in
the complaint and what we will do is
follow the same process that we have for
an external review so for example for a
prior authorization that's been disputed
it will go out to external review a
third party will determine whether or
not the prior R should be granted or not
similarly we'll take in the complaint
we'll send it off to the IDR that we
contract with here at the state level
they'll make the determination and then
okay now you inquire um thanks for your
time I uh this is anecdotal so uh my my
impression has been that um there has
been some private Equity investments
into uh the medical field Health Care
field and and I was just wondering is is
and I I came away with the impression
that that was where some of the conflict
uh happens that's where you get a
surprise in your bill and so I was just
wondering um if you have any kind of
comment on um how this is going to
improve that sure issue so I can't speak
in any detail to the private Equity
piece but what I can tell you is how a
balanced Bill essentially comes to be
and boy you're going to get an education
on this later today when we start
talking about ground ambulances which by
the way may I add is not included in
this bill
we deal with everything except ground
ambulance it's a thorny issue you'll
hear more about it today there's a
reason why the federal government was
able to handle helicopter rides before
they were able to handle ground
ambulance it's really
thorny how a balance Bill comes to be is
you will have a facility or a provider
who is not in
network but it's not readily apparent to
the patient that that facility or that
individual is not in network so for
example you fall someplace they take you
to the
hospital we want you to focus on making
sure that you're getting the care that
you need and you're getting better we
don't want to have you to have to worry
about whether or not that particular
hospital is in network and therefore you
fearing that you're going to get a bill
so these protections will prevent that
for emergency room visits and other
things like that but what happens is is
that the insurance carrier will have a
minimum allowed amount by which they
will pay an out of network provider
so whatever the bill is they'll have a
certain percentage of that that they'll
pay but there'll be a Delta between what
they're going to pay and what the bill
is and the balance of that is ultimately
what goes to the consumer and those are
the types of things that we very fearful
of because number one in many instances
it's out of the patients hands and
number two they have no idea that it's
coming and some of these balanced bills
can be really large bills and can be a
real Financial strain on patients so
that that is our concern and those are
the reasons why we want to bring these
more expansive protections to the state
level the other common thing that we see
that again is dealt with to a less
degree in current state law but will be
dealt with more comprehensively with
passage of Senate Bill 173 is you'll go
in for surgery the facility is a network
the doctor the surgeon is a network but
the anes theologist is not and so there
again we don't want the patient to be in
the position of sitting there on the
table getting ready for surgery and say
okay doctor I know you're in my network
but ma'am who are you and are you in my
network I mean that's an absurd scenario
to put a patient in so again that would
that would be uh addressed through
passage of this bill Keith can I follow
up oh followup
um now that this is going to be come law
here um is there any
um opportunities for additional funding
if you have run
into a lot of issues that take some time
from the federal government so we're
always seeking out opportunities to take
advantage of resources that are
available I think the state Prides
itself on getting good return on
investment from the federal government
we'll certainly do our part uh to
advance that what I can say is is we're
not anticipating a Lar large number of
appeals to come through so again we've
had state level balance billing
protections on the book since in in
effect since 2019 passed in 2018 went
into effect in
2019 to date the insurance department
has received a grand total of zero
requests for us to arbitrate a dispute
and the reason why in my opinion and my
theory on this is because the parties
don't want us to be the ones who decide
the dispute because once you start doing
that you start setting precedent for a
fee schedule which the parties in many
cases do not want so the incentive is
there for both sides to negotiate with
themselves reasonably and come up with
what is actually a fair value for those
Services we think that some of those
Dynamics are still going to be very much
in play with the passage of 173 though
the dispute resolution process will be
different representa Pella did you have
a question and then representative
Spears yes um thank you for taking my
question so I wanted to know about the
ground ambulance so that's definitely
excluded that is excluded air is
included air and then I have a followup
about actually how balanc sure work so
100% ground ambulance is not dealt with
in this bill again we'll talk about that
later today yes that's a separate issue
when the no surprises Act initially
passed it did deal with balance billing
issues related to um air ambulance uh
helicopters uh the dart U uh program
here in New Hampshire I think is
something you may be familiar with um my
understanding is that that was subject
to some litigation and again don't quote
me on this but I think they ran into
some issues with how the no surprises
act impacted FAA regulation
and that was where the rub came in so I
think that has since Fallen away but
again I humorously noted that the
federal government was able to come up
with a proposed solution to air
ambulances before they were able to deal
with ground ambulances okay which I have
like a real all right so my real
question is can you help
summarize not what is in current statue
but for this bill can you help summarize
um what is there what is the changes to
the balance billing and what are you
recommending now that the insurance
companies do between out of network in
network can you just summarize for us
exactly what this bill is doing sure so
for me there are two main issues and
then Alex can maybe give his to for me
the two big issues are it synchronizes
state law with federal law so you're
going to have the same protections
whether you're dealing with a fully
insured plan which is dealt with by the
federal government or whether you're
dealing with a self-funded plan excuse
me fully is US self is the federal
government will have the same basic
protections um so that's consistent so I
think that's going to improve uh doing
business in New Hampshire that you're
not going to have two sets of Standards
the second big thing that I would point
out is the independent dispute
resolution process again while you'll
have the option to go the federal or the
state route the process itself will be
the same so again we're synchronizing
and we're harmonizing ing what the no
surprises act provides with State
Statute Alex do you have some others yes
the only thing I would emphasize um
beyond that is that by harmonizing with
the federal no surprises act we are
expanding the footprint of the state no
surprises act um the state as it exists
um only applies to uh when you go to
inetwork hospital and then you see an
anesthesiologist or radiologist or a
lab um through this harmonization
process it'll be any provider who's out
of network if you're an in network
Hospital you'll be covered by the
prohibition on balanced billing and then
it also deals with any emergency
services that you receive at a
non-participating provider so it's a
bigger footprint and it lines up with
the federal law and then representative
I remember the last portion of your
question there what I hope this will do
is is to further encourage carriers and
providers to negotiate with each other
to get in network because once you're in
network you don't have to worry about
any of these things you have an you know
you've got a contract you've got a
negotiated rate you're Off to the Races
it's smooth sailing U so hopefully this
bill will be a further incentive for
those types of conversations to take
place okay last one um and help us
understand what segments of the insured
population right there's lots of
segments so is this everybody or just
certain segments so for fully insured
which is what we regulate those fully
insured commercial products they will
now have the same level of protections
from balance billing as is provided
under federal law for self-funded plans
so we're matching our state level
protections with the federal
protections representative
spear this is a a simple clarification
question question on page two uh around
line
12 could you explain what those that
string of words mean
sure page two line 12 you said page two
line 12 representative yeah yeah there's
a string of words there I I can't figure
out what they're saying you want to read
the words just so we know I can try yeah
uh paragraph one shall not apply with
respect to items or Services other than
items or services that qualify as
ancillaries Services Under 42 USC
section 30 3 300 gg- 132 B2 and three
furnished by a non-participating
provider to a covered person if the
provider satisfies the notice and can
send criteria under oh you can read the
rest of it okay
um that for us please we don't need to
apologize for the obscurity of this
language because it's word for word from
the federal statute so they're the on
who are obscure but basically um what it
allows
for um in certain situations the
patients can wave uh the right to be
protected from balanced billing if
they're in network and they are notified
of their rights and they want to go
ahead and get services from this autof
network provider they can wave it under
certain yes yes you have to forgive me I
never would have guessed that okay
so I have a question um this parallel
dispute resolution process how do the
parties decide whether to use the state
or federal uh process when is it decided
how is it decided um the way we um got
it to work is that basically we treat
only the health care providers as the
grieved party so it's the provider who
gets to decide whether to go with the
state process or the federal process for
so there's this 20-day time limit if the
provider wants to go with the state
process you have to act within that 20
days and if you want the federal process
um you can go beyond the 20 days to the
30-day Federal deadline and and then
just to follow up on that uh in your
current budget you can manage this
parallel process standing it up and yes
we are very confident that we can do
that it's not going to require any
additional staff because as I said we'll
just contract with the third party rdrs
we'll send that out to them it'll come
back in it should not take any more
effort or work than it does for our
current external review process which
we've got bandwidth and capacity to
handle all right great any further
questions from the
committee all right seeing none thank
you for your testimony thank you all and
I have one more card here for 173 and
it's um
Alexandra I can't I can't read your last
name I'm sorry you can just tell us
begins with an s from the uh New
Hampshire Department of Justice good
morning Alexander snowski for the
Department of Justice members of the
committee um so I am an Assistant
Attorney General with the consumer
protection and Anti-Trust Bureau and I'm
here to speak solely on the portion that
adds the balance billing provision to
the consumer protection act under
358a um so I want I just want to mention
we've spoken to the insurance department
on this part of it um but under RSA 358
A3 there's an exemption for trade or
Commerce that is regulated and subject
to the jurisdiction of the insurance
commission and they believe that this
the portion that we are regulating is
not subject to their jurisdiction where
we would be regulating is the final bill
from the provider to the consumer
directly so all the Upstream stuff is
with the insurance department and we
would be regulating the bill the
prohibited balance bill from the
consumer another thing we always talk
about our resources so they the
insurance department stated to us that
they haven't received a lot of
complaints on this issue um we believe
there would there will be some but we
don't think this will be um a strain on
our resources but we welcome the
opportunity to come back in case that it
turns out to be happy to take any
questions all right thank you for your
testimony any questions from the
committee all right seeing none thank
you for your testimony and we have about
two minutes before the next hearing and
room I I have no cards for
176 so if anybody is willing to testify
card
for
e
right we'll open the hearing for house
uh Senate Bill 176 uh relative to
insurance coverage for pelvic floor
therapy and uh would you introduce
yourself for the record state
representative Brian Cole
Manchester Senate Bill
176 relative to insurance coverage for
pelvic floor
therapy this bill directs insurance
commissioner to provide guidance and
report on insurance coverage for pelvic
floor therapy and I think we're all
interested to find out what exactly that
is all right thank you and uh we'll call
Hardy croll from a
ahip uh to tell us a little more about
this
bill um good morning uh Mr chairman and
members of the committee uh for the
record my name is Heidi croll I work at
Gallagher cahan and gartell and I
represent ahip which is America's health
insurance plans I wasn't necessarily
planning on speaking on on this one I
signed up neutral um but thought it
might be helpful to um say a few words
since no one else was here to speak on
the bill um so this issue came up so
this is a bill that was carried over
from last
year and um I think the concern that was
was brought
by um at least one provider group um uh
was concerned that carriers weren't
covering this um carriers are covering
um pelvic Flo therapy when it is
medically deemed medically necessary um
and so I think it was determined um when
this bill was in the um Senate that
perhaps just some um uh additional
guidance from the Department um which is
the first um
uh part of the bill um written guidance
typically would come from the Department
in the form of a bulletin um and then
potentially some education around this
um for the providers um might be
valuable um and then the commissioner
agreed simply to look at um as it says
the current scope and adequacy of Health
Care coverage for pelvic floor therapy
and if there are any gaps um that they
would um be able to bring that to the
attention of the legislature so um it's
pretty pretty straightforward um and
i''d be happy to try to answer any
questions could you just explain to us
what pelvic floor therapy is so we have
a baseline sure um so I think the issue
um comes up typically um around
childbirth um and rather and you know I
guess if the public floor muscles have
become um damaged or stretched as part
of the pregnancy process or birthing
process all right thank you
representative
spear based on the wording of this bill
should it actually be a bill or should
it have been a request of the uh
insurance department it doesn't seem
like it's the wording of it seems like
it should be a bill at all it's just a
report yeah certain certainly I I don't
want to speak for the department but um
they're always very willing to be
helpful and so to your point I think
probably that could have been an
alternative path um simply to ask them
to to take care of a couple of tasks
so e we can't claim credit as
politicians if we don't make it a bill
right all right uh any other
questions questions representative just
a quick question who typically um does
this therapy like I mean is it as nurse
practitioner yeah I I think it's
generally um physical therapist although
I um I think that there may be people
who specialize in this type of therapy
as well or it may be a type of therapy
that's um delivered in the context of
maybe other kind of um pregnancy and
birthing um services that may be
provided um and so again I think that
might be back to the point around um
just the education for providers around
this um so Y and you had said earlier
that this is already covered generally
by the so if this is so if it's deemed
to be a medically necessary if there's
some sort of diagnosis um and it's this
therapy is deemed to be medically
necessary and appropriate that it would
um you know help kind of heal or or uh
you know be an appropriate treatment um
then carriers are covering it um it's
not going to be covered if it's a um if
there is no diagnosis and it's just
being done as kind of a prophylactic um
therapy then that would be the
responsibility of the patient um that
they might be able to do this you know
as part of their exercise routine all
right thank you representative P thank
you um this might be very granular but
so will the
report review what is medically
necessary is that the parameters of this
report so that we don't get into the you
know kind of the Weeds on what may be
beneficial but not medically necessary
so we do have a atory definition of
medical necessity um already on in in
the laws in New Hampshire so um the
report or the guidance could certainly
reference reference those guid that the
guidance around what what is medically
necessary um right and just to to clear
you know to determine um so again the
for example the department again I don't
want to speak for them because I don't
know exactly how they would do an
approach but they might look at their um
they have a claim stated datase where
they collect claims from all of the
payers so they might look there to see
um uh what what that shows for coverage
what that might show for denials there's
an um that includes when there's a
denial it will give a reason there's an
you know um information about the reason
for denial so um they might take a look
at you know that sort of data so but yes
I think to answer your point I think
that they to answer your question I
think that they would um reference
medical
necessity all right uh seeing no further
questions thank you for Testimony sir
and we have uh one more card and this is
department good morning Jason Dexter New
Hampshire insurance department assistant
commissioner just wanted to speak
quickly to one of the questions that
came up
um we agree it reads more like a request
uh we did do a a report in March that we
provided uh that details a lot of these
issues we can provide that report to
this committee as well um you know our
general responses we think that there is
um this coverage is available sometimes
there's network issues certain providers
that are out in the market aren't in
network and that tends to be um
an issue but other than that we'll be
happy to forward the
report could you send that to us in time
for the subcomittee hearing subcommittee
uh work session you can go today okay
perfect representative Suk thank you for
uh coming to visit us sure and uh you're
you're basically you're saying that this
bill has already been
answered if I understand it correctly
well I see the sponsor here she may not
maybe able to give some insight to that
but we tried to respond to it
immediately because we felt it was
something we could do in house there are
times when we have requests that we need
to send um outside the department this
one we felt to have the information to
do it so we just felt we provide it
thank you you're welcome all right I see
no further
questions uh thank you for your
testimony thank you and then the last
so we had a question earlier uh is
legislation for this necessary maybe you
can answer that question thank you yes
sure hi committee for the record I'm
Senator Rebecca Perkins quoka and my
grave apologies for being late I'm in um
committee downstairs and we just we're
in a line of questioning um so I hear
your question about whether the
legislation is necessary I'm happy to
talk with the Department further about
that but as amended by the Senate this
bill
um asks for
clarity about coverage for our providers
so what we're finding is that the
experience of our providers in the field
is that there's a little bit of
uncertainty around reimbursement and so
um even though the carriers are saying
um pelvic floor therapy is covered and
the department has done this wonderful
report which I very much appreciate I
think it continues to highlight that um
there's still some
ambiguity about under what codes um
treatment can be submitted to guarantee
reimbursement and so it becomes a small
business issue because our providers
can't open up a practice because they're
not certain of their revenue stream and
so we want to guarantee our patients
have access and we want to create
Clarity for those providers in terms of
planning their business you know if they
need to grow or take certain number of
appointments making sure they know which
codes are going to work to get money in
the door to cover those obligations and
so it's been great to work with the
Department um if this is something
they're willing to do without
legislation that's fine too but I do
think some sort of written clarification
is needed and um and this bill has been
impress for a long time I actually was
reflecting this morning I introduced it
on February 1st of 2023 in the Senate um
you know it was re-referred to interim
study it was studied this fall this was
the amendment that was agreed to it was
adopted in January AR and I've since had
a whole another baby and created another
human in this world so um you know I
think it would be important to to just
sort of see this work through and just
make sure that those small business
owners and those providers have the
clarity they
need just a a question for you um the
language in the bill is fairly generic
and it sounds like since uh this was
filed we have a report that may be
mostly complete yes but there may be
gaps in the report and your vision for
what this bill is supposed to accomplish
could you give us we have a subcommittee
work session uh on this bill in a week
or two could you give us some analysis
on any deficiencies in the in the report
that the department generated and that
maybe that would be an amendment for
this bill to sort of clarify what gaps
uh specific gaps need to be addressed
that's a great suggestion Vice chair and
I appre appreciate the opportunity yes I
will certainly do that great cool any
committee all right seeing none thank
you for coming and visiting thank you
very much for having me and apologies
again for being
late cool all right uh the next hearing
is until 11 o'clock so we have a 20
break
e
we're gonna get started in a minute
is anyone here from the Senate to
bill
yeah is is anyone here from the Senate
to introduce the next bill okay
excellent and you submitted a pin card
yes I oh okay
well okay well when you're when you're
done if you could and just introduce
yourself for the record so we'll start
the hearing for Senate Bill 1 77
relative to health insurance coverage of
prosthetics for children under 19 years
of
age good morning U members of house
Commerce and consumer affairs um for the
record and representative em and you're
chair chairing right now uh yeah
pretending to I'm sure so good morning
uh chair Amon and other members U my
name is supren the state senator from
District 5 covering a large part of uh
Grafton County Sullivan County and one
lovely community in marac County the
beautiful town of New London so I'm here
today to introduce to you Senate Bill
177 this is a bill that was actually
retained in the Senate so that we could
do some more work on it before it came
to the house and I'll explain a little
bit about its progress as we go but what
we're working on here and this is titled
so no so New Hampshire kids can move is
legislation that will require that our
private payers cover at one activity
specific prosthetic okay for a child 18
years of age okay or younger and when we
first started out we were talking about
Orthotics and Prosthetics but in the
course of doing an insurance mandate
review the recommendations came back and
said that focusing on the prosthetic was
where most of the support and the data
was was moved in was focused in that
direction so let me just tell you a
little bit about um why we're here and
why this is so important to me and my um
in my full-time world I mean I'm a
paramedic but I'm also the executive
director of a group called The American
trauma Society we support Trauma Centers
and the trauma survivors Network
throughout the country and I have had
the honor of working with members of the
limb loss community and this community
had came to me come come to me
originally through trauma but the truth
is not just traumatic events that lead
to limb loss it's also cancer and it
also you could be born have a congenital
defect what we're trying to do here is
bring basically make it equal for the
children in the limb loss Community to
be able to
play and play on the you know be on the
playground play sports lead an active
lifestyle just like any other child um
our concern or my concern when taking
this on initially besides the fact fact
that they just didn't have access um and
had to pay for this was that you know
these kids they should be able to play
sports just like anybody else they
should be in the playground I remember
how we had what we have we play
dodgeball I don't know if they allow you
to do that anymore dodgeball kickball
whatever it might be but it Al is also
and it's spoken to in the insurance
mandate review this promotes a healthy
lifestyle because so we are doing two
things here you know bringing
inclusiveness and act you know being
bringing these children into a place
where they are comfortably and healthy
comfortably and in a health status part
of their community so that is the focus
of this other states have been working
on this legislation and Maggie bomber is
here from the hangar Clinic that will
talk about some of the other states that
have adopted um this but here's one of
the things that I know and Maggie will
talk to this is that under the
Affordable Care Act the essential health
benefits specifically rehabilitative
services and device
are covered therefore these devices
should be covered so what happens is
under these benefits there's a limb of
what they call like daily living just
and that would be you know for maybe
maybe when you go to school maybe when
you're you go to um you know a holiday
whatever the the day-to-day activity is
um but there's
also the requirement for a second device
and that could be an activity specific
specific we are not asking for multiple
specific devices we're asking under this
bill as amended for an activity one
activity specific device with all the
pieces and parts that go with it um and
also that this is deemed as medically
necessary that language was brought in
here as well so that is um that's what I
have to say today and I'm hoping that
you know I'll wrap up by saying New
Hampshire children and their family
shouldn't have to apply for Grants or
hold bake sales to afford an activity
specific device so they can live their
best and active life um I look forward
to your support I think this is one of
there's not
a the numbers are low in how many we may
need to provide but what is really high
and of the greatest importance is this
quality of life and ability to be part
of their school their Sports whatever
they might want to do so thank you for
taking my testimony I will try to answer
questions you might have some of the
very technical work will come um with
Maggie bomber U from Hangar clinic and
some of the folks she's brought with her
thank
you represent burs thank you senator for
taking my question am I I mean kids kids
do multiple Sports in a year I mean they
may do winter activities things sports
that are in different kinds of we
weather so why are we limiting it to one
activity the prothetic for one activity
per year thank you for the question
representative Barrow so this
is it's a great question but as you know
being a legislator there are compromises
that you have to come to and if the
compromise is not having this covered
versus having one covered then I you
know then I'm advocating for let's have
one covered thank you I just would
Advocate we go the next step next time
around and get another one thank you
representative
patril yes thank you I was going to ask
if and perhaps someone else has the
answer um the number of kids that might
be affected by this and if one device
would cover most of the activities
believe in it's per year correct because
kids grow so it would it's one device
per year it's as they need so it can be
it's aligned with grow with growth but
at at a Max yes at a Max of one special
they might not need more it's going to
depend on their growth right so it's one
per year correct okay depending on their
growth the numbers of kids and if less
than 10 is what the insurance mandate
review has listed in it yes and um oh
sorry what uh segments of the insured
with this uh be so it's state local
private private the private payers the
state is exempt from this it doesn't um
cover self-funded plans under dur Orissa
so it's only a very small of the insured
population correct so what happens to
the state and the
other um well we'd certainly be happy to
take that up next so incrementally um
this has been the movement and if we can
make if we can make steps into that
Community pardon the pun but make the
steps into those communities we
certainly would be happy to or I'd
certainly be happy to all representative
Solan thank you Senator um so you just
mentioned or I got caught up in when you
said this is medically necessary so um
does that mean like somebody will say
this is medic necessary for these second
second activity based Sports based
whatever you want to call it um
prosthetic that would be deemed medical
medically necessary in in this statute
is that how that would work thank you
representative Sullivan I'll put there's
a bright light behind you I don't know
if it's a it's okay it's like it's just
the sun shining so we must get used to
that U so that's why I'm scrin a little
uh
so one act so one limb of daily living
mhm one activity
specific and the it would need to be
deemed you know a physician or care
provider would need to say that this was
medically necessary okay like that
they've qualified and it was necessary
for
them okay so um to be clear I'm very
supportive of this I'm just a little
concerned could that potentially open
like a loophole for them to say well
clearly it's not medically necessary
because these people can survive without
this I'm just worried that it could open
up some sort of loophole so maybe you've
thought about that I have thought about
that so it's not it links into the
statute there is a um there's like I
don't I think dispute resolution it
might so if you medically necessary it
gets denied then there's the next level
that you can take it to so there's an
opportunity um the intent here is not to
open a loophole and close it and thank
you for identifying that but uh we have
at least two guards at the door to try
to make sure that these children can get
these activity specific limbs when it's
when it's deemed when it's necessary
questions okay one quick one quick one
and I'm sorry this might be again in the
weeds but are these currently covered or
it really depends on the insurance
company they're they're not covered at
all not at
all not at all okay thank you all right
and I I did find your cards s an
apprentice I apologize oh no it's okay I
didn't realize I Jessica must have done
it cor no wait have to wait till he
calls you all right thank you for your
testimony all
right all right so we have four cards
here
um we'll call up Aiden
Coler would you like to
testify yeah and you can come with your
right he'd like me to go first sure you
guys can sit there's two chairs there
you can both have a
seat and talk right into the microphone
when you're you're ready and uh just
introduce yourself for the record and
the town you live in okay uh and tell us
what's on your
mind do you want to go first or you want
me
okay thank you for allowing us to speak
today um my name is Samantha Collier
from Marram New Hampshire this is my son
Aiden uh he is an 11-year-old cancer
survivor who lost his leg in exchange
for better odds of survivorship we are
here today in support of SB 177 Aden was
diagnosed with rabdo myos saroma at the
end of March 2021 and became an amputee
at the very beginning of June 2021
before getting sick Aiden was a very
active child and even then chemo
couldn't keep him down he was fitted for
his first prosthetic in August 2021 and
walked independently just a few weeks
later it wasn't long before Aiden was
ready to return to the sports and
activities with friends he sorely missed
we then found out that running blades
were not covered by insurance and our
put weight back on this caused his
socket to no longer fit and he returned
to walk working with his walking leg
this leg is not only bulkier with the
knee but heavier and he had to adjust
his gate to run and keep up with his
friends we again turned to borne to run
and got in line for financing for a new
blade because we didn't have the money
to replace it it took several months
until Aiden's turn for funding again
which we were grateful for that they
could cover he received his new socket
in March 2024 and began working right
away to regain the skills he lost in the
months being without his blade a weight
and loss that wouldn't have happened had
our insurance been required to cover his
prosthetic wasting valuable time and
skills that he had learned such as
proper pressure to his blade how to use
the spring of the carbon fiber for more
power and keeping his body properly
aligned this resulted in a lot of
frustration on Aiden's part because it
felt like he had been set back today
Aiden is getting ready to run the bionic
5K in Cambridge on April 28th and we
feel so fortunate that we were able to
find someone to finance his blade
because Insurance didn't find an
accessible and active lifestyle to be
medically necessary we along with many
parents of children with limb difference
feel the frustration that our children
aren't given access to the Prosthetics
to continue to do and try activities
they love to lead full and happy lives
especially in their
childhood we feel the worry of trying to
figure out how to fund the next socket
when our children out grow their current
ones because we know that while
foundations exist the funds may not
always be available we encourage
everyone before us with all their limbs
to think how fortunate they are to be
able to participate in activities they
enjoy and to vote in favor of kids who
need something extra to participate in
their favorite
activities all right thank you and Aiden
would you like to tell us what's on your
just tell us tell us what you're
thinking it's
okay do you want me to read
yours why don't you start with your name
and where do where you go to school and
of I do you want me to say it for
you it's okay
buddy what grade are you
in sixth grade great you do Sports yeah
what kind of sports do you I do soccer I
really like
soccer and you GNA be running
soon yeah I run a
lot why do you need to run you said you
you always have to be ready to run I
because you just never know when you
need to
run you you you never really know when
run soccer
and you like to play midfield right yeah
up and down I don't like
defense represent pus you have a
question hi yes Aiden you play soccer in
the fall correct yes and in the spring
okay are you going to be uh doing any
spring Sports which require running
also yes
soccer oh okay he plays it both in both
fall and spring okay I thought you'd go
after for something really crazy like
lacrosse like I used to
do any other questions represent Cole
thank you thank you for taking my
question thanks for being here today so
you've had the prosthetic for about
three years now uh yeah how many how
many occasions have Arisen where you
needed to replace it in that threeyear
span two yeah yeah like two because I
okay can you give us an idea what the
cost is for the
prospe or his mother one the two 20,000
it was $20,000 yeah around like
$20,000 20 grand I think okay thank
you represent Bros um this we do
something called would you believe and
I'm going to say would you believe you
said sometimes you need to run we feel
that way a lot in this committee we feel
like we need to run out of here but the
other thing I wanted to say to you
there's a movie I don't know if you've
seen Jerry Maguire uh with Tom Cruz and
uh the character says to to Tom Cruz you
Aiden all right any other questions
repres so uh is he is the one
appropriate or would he need different
ones for different
activities do you want me to answer that
one uh
yeah yes uh so for right now his running
blade is kind of his go-to um there are
different things like you know if he
decides in the future to pursue say
swimming or something more water-based
he would we would look more for a
water-based um prosthesis but as of
right now he is both feet on well foot
on the ground and a and a hook there and
he's he's really happy with you know
working with his running blade he
actually wears it every day instead of
his walking leg because it's just easier
for him as a child to just take off and
go and did he a real quick follow up so
has he outgrown them or did he wear them
out for the replacement he uh both he
actually um said he actually cracked the
one running blade for because of
excessive use um which was covered under
warranty and then he did outgrow his
socket the one so he outgrew one and yes
outus the other okay thank you
yes all right any further questions from
the committee all right seeing none
thank you both for your
job so uh we have another in support uh
Step hi everyone my name is Kate Martin
and I'm a certified prosthetist
orthotist at nextstep bionics and
Prosthetics in Manchester New
Hampshire I grew up in westerland
attended Keen high and I'm a Plymouth
State graduate it's safe to say I love
this state I appreciate the opportunity
to speak today in support of s SP
177 as a clinician I've seen the
significant impact recreational proses
can have on a patient's physical and
mental health unfortunately recreational
prostheses can be rather costly ranging
from 5,000 to upwards of
$50,000 for children this cost can
increase rapidly as frequent replacement
is necessary due to
growth I think we can all agree you
would never use your rake to shovel snow
or wear dress shoes to run a 5k instead
you would likely use a specific tool or
choose gear that is most appropriate
allowing you to perform at your best
deeming a recreational prosthesis not
medically necessary is denying a child
access to tools that will allow them to
per perform at their best and just be a
kid this is particularly problematic as
children with disabilities are 4.5 times
less likely to engage in physical
activity compared to their peers
furthermore the prevalence of obesity in
children with disabilities is almost
twice that of children without
disabilities although a child's everyday
prosthesis may allow them to chase their
sibling around the house it likely
cannot withstand going in the ocean or
keeping up with teammates at a baseball
practice sp17 7 will address this issue
by requiring State Commercial insurers
to cover activity specific prcs for
enroles 19 years and under SB 177 will
provide children with limb loss and limb
difference access to prosthetic care
they need to live active full
lives with the increase in mental and
physical health issues including
depression and obesity I believe that
this investment would actually lower
future health care costs Next Step
includes three of the 11 OMP facilities
in New Hampshire within these three
clinics children under the age of 18
make up only 7% of the prosthetic
patients we see if passed the cost to
commercial insurance companies would be
nominal however the impact would be
substantial the children of the Granite
State deserve better and that is why I
urge you to support this important
legislation and help its passage into
law I would like to personally invite
you to visit our facility in Manchester
to meet with myself children and
families who would benefit from this
bill to provide you with a greater
understanding of the challenges that
these individuals face and how SB 177
can change their lives and Future Health
thank you for your
consideration thank you for Testimony uh
representative
post I'm on okay sorry um so a question
is as kids grow and it their leg doesn't
fit into it or arm or whatever they have
um is there not a way to improve upon
like it kind of change it up like with
where it would
fit is there to to reduce the cost for
that or does it have to be one
continuous could it be interchangeable I
guess yeah they it would sort of depend
on what the issue is but certainly if
volume is an issue um there's many
different adjustments we can do we can
thin out the socket we can open up the
back um we could even change liners to a
thinner liner or something like that if
needed um those are things that we
choose to do sort of already too just to
reduce the amount of appointments
patients have we know that's not really
practical if they have to keep coming
back um I know that the feet usually
have about a three-year warranty so as
long as a foot isn't no longer
appropriate due to size if it were to
break we can send it in and get a new
one no cost um so there's a lot of
different ways that we can prolong
something as long as we can but then
there comes a time where it's just not
going to fit anywhere right well great
thank you for
that representative Tusk uh thank you
Kate uh I have a question I don't know
if you can answer or not this bill is
for uh young people under 19 is there in
effect any bills for people over 19 that
are already in
force so I know in the state of
Massachusetts um this is moving forward
to include adults as well um I know
right now this is where we stand 19
years in under and under but certainly
as a clinician I think that could be
something for the future to focus on but
there is nothing in place right now so
those are not covered for 19 and up
thank
you any other
questions uh do you have written
testimony yep that'd be great the clerk
I think Samantha Samantha so you also
have written testimony yeah if you don't
mind submitting it that would be great
okay so we last card okay so last card
barin good morning good
morning thank thanks everyone for having
me my name is Maggie bomber I'm actually
a resident of
Massachusetts um and I'm here
representing Hangar Clinic which is the
largest provider of prosthetic and
orthotic Clinical Services in the
country um so I'm also the immediate
past president of the National
Association for the advancement of
Orthotics and Prosthetics which
represents the limb loss and limb
difference Community I'm also a person
with an upper extremity limb loss and I
wear a prosthetic arm every day uh I've
been lucky enough to be participating in
the so everybody can move initiative
which Senator Apprentice had mentioned
uh this is a movement to pass laws in
all states that ensure coverage of
orthoses and prostheses for physical
activity so in response to the question
that was just asked there are actually
five states that have passed these bills
since 2023 in chronological order we
have Maine Arkansas Colorado New Mexico
and Illinois in Maine this is for
prosthetic only and for those under 18
uh in Arkansas it's all ages in Colorado
it's also all ages and in New Mexico
it's also all ages and Illinois as well
so Maine is the only state so far that
only passed it for those under
18 there's also two more bills that are
very close to passage in both Maryland
and uh Minnesota and our goal is to
enable individuals with limb loss and
limb difference to participate in
exercise Recreation and physical
activities to remain healthy fit and
functional so in New Hampshire there are
nearly 177,000 people living with limb
loss and limb difference and back in
2003 New Hampshire passed an Orthotics
and Prosthetics Insurance fairness
otherwise known as parity law to ensure
adequate coverage of daily use
Prosthetics in state regulated
commercial insurance plans um this
prevented any arbitrary Caps or
restrictions from coverage which we were
seeing across the country so there were
20 states that pass similar laws around
um between 2000 and
2012 so this bill will essentially be an
amendment of that insurance Fair
fairness law to ensure that those under
18 have access to uh prostheses for
physical activity the cost of this is
minimal as was noted previously uh we
have done a recent fiscal and social
impact report that estimates the cost in
New Hampshire to be between 1 and 5
cents per member per month
we also predict millions of dollars in
cost savings per year based on improved
Health outcomes and the reduction of
costly secondary health conditions
including heart disease diabetes and
obesity which collectively cost the US
Health Care System $626 billion per year
uh knee and hip problems resulting from
a lack of appropriate prosthetic care
can also result in costs ranging from
80,000 to
$150,000 over the course of a single
person's lifetime so I uh am lucky
enough to have access to coverage for a
prosthesis for physical activity through
my employer which you can see here it's
pretty different than this one right
does very different things I have
several uh attachments that help me do
different activities so this one is
specifically for yoga uh then I also
have an attachment for weightlifting
skiing and
biking so this device enables me to be
Physically Active through all of those
activities which has greatly aided me in
my personal recovery increasing my
confidence as well as physical and
emotional while beinging after
amputation of my forearm in hand back in
2012 and we believe the young residents
of New Hampshire also deserve the same
access to care for those who have limb
loss in limb difference uh we also want
to thank the payers who've been a
pivotal part of this process uh through
the Senate and working with us to make
sure that we could get something that we
all agreed on across the table so thank
you very much and I'm happy to take any
questions okay representative
grassing thank you thank you for taking
my question uh question I have when they
when they looked at Cost here and I I
noticed one other person that testified
today talked about the onset of diabetes
and young children who are not able to
be as active is there any relationship
or there have been any studies of of how
what costs have been avoided uh by
providing PR ICS to these children and
allowing them to run when they want when
they really need to run uh I'm not aware
of studies specifically on prostheses
but there's certainly a lot of
information from the CDC about how
physical activity prevents and a
ameliorates those conditions so we do
have some of that information in our
handout um also as far as the fiscal and
social impact report that we had drafted
it does include an analysis of you know
preventative measures of access to
physical activity and how that would
save
money okay thank you very much thank you
and you have written testimony I do
thank
you okay having no more cards anybody
else would like to
testify all right seeing none we will
hearing
for
e
um
hearing open the hearing for Senate Bill
312 relative to third party liability in
Medicaid and here from the prime sponsor
Senator Bell good
afternoon good
afternoon thank you for hearing my bill
and it's um after lunch so I'll try and
awake um for the record my name is
Regina berzel state senator senator for
district 19 which encompasses the towns
of Derry Hamstead and
Windham and I am the prime sponsor of
Senate Bill
312 which is um third party liability in
Medicaid this was actually a bill that
was requested from the Department of
Health and Human
Services it provides for a health carer
acceptance liability to third parties
under the Medicaid procedures John
Williams is here today he will provide
you with an overview of three uh Senate
Bill 312 and field some of the questions
from the committee
um so remedial legislation required for
federal compliance seeks uh to amend um
RSA 67 colon
B-
4-b five to require that responsible
thirdparty paays in Medicaid cannot
refuse payment for an item or service
solely on the basis that such item or
service did not receive prior
authorization under the third party's
Rule and the length of time a third-
party payer has to respond to an inquiry
within 60 days of receiving the inquiry
so uh John Williams is here he'll kind
of um interpret that for you and I will
questions you get off
John so where did where did where did
you where did you get stuck right in
front of you
John oh right in front of you oh it was
all right John Williams and
tsha Tashia planchard Tasha
Tasha okay chairman hunt members of the
Commerce and consumer affairs committee
uh for the record my name is John
Williams I'm the director of legislative
affairs for the New Hampshire Department
of Health Services and with me today is
Tasha Blancher and I'm the administrator
for the Bureau of program Integrity in
Department of Health and Human Services
and we wanted to thank Senator birdell
she actually did a wonderful job
introducing this bill and gave you a
very concise explanation of what is uh
being accomplished I I want to do
something awkward here yes I want you to
tell us a
story tell us how what goes on why
because we don't know anything
about Medicaid and re tell us give it
examp give us give us a story of what
how what's going on here and you know
why we were in violation of cms's rules
and and and you just tell help us
understand what this make a scenario
give us a story so so once upon a time
uh they created a program called called
Medicaid and as part of Medicaid they
there's two different types of Medicaid
standard Medicaid and as you know the
Medicaid expansion population so uh a
number of New Hampshire's residents who
go to bed at night and get bedtime
stories as well uh are covered by medic
or Medicaid expansion let's say that
that person let's say John because
John's a great name to pick for for the
both of us uh that that John Johnny uh
just got his driver's license and he's
he's driving on the road and doing all
the right things according to motor
vehicle laws and all of a sudden
somebody who was very Reckless slammed
into poor Johnny not only damaging the
car but hurting Johnny who's covered by
Medicaid and there are medical expenses
paid on behalf of Johnny by the state of
New Hampshire to taxpayers and
and half of it General funds typically
and the other half ferally funded uh
it's actually a higher percentage uh 90
9010 for those who are in the expansion
population so that's part of the story
and then the story gets a little bit
more complicated uh so there's a third
party out there insurer that provides
the insurance coverage for the wrongdoer
here so let's find somebody who we can
pick for a wrongdoer so they're insur
they're insured in this case with the
other the mot they're they're insured
the minimum insurance policy and we're
gon to call him affectionately Jeb Jeb
is a really nice man and just you just
got to love Jeb but he was Reckless on
the state and but but he was covered for
uh uh for his insurance on his motor
vehicle including for personal body
injury to another individual that he get
harmed right so all of a sudden you know
everything gets going really well Johnny
gets the medical treatment that Johnny
uh needs and and Johnny gets a full
recovery so but then there's like a
price tag for for that paid by the state
in part and for that medical care and
then that's when Tasha Tasha's a great
story name too it sounds almost like you
know a you know what are those Brothers
Grims kind of story so so so Tasha uh
finds out that there's this insurer out
there who is going to be responsible for
paying back the state of New Hampshire
for those medical assistant that be an
auto insurance company yes it could be
an a because there's some there's 50 you
know let's say 5025 you had some Auto
Insurance company had some liability
here yeah which which is the second
chapter in the next book which is a
great example of another
scenario and so so so Tasha then sends a
claims form to this insurer Who
currently says well under your New
Hampshire law it doesn't it says doesn't
say anything about priorization so
because we never got priorization uh and
I know we're now getting to health
insurance a little away from the car
insurance thing but yeah yeah this is
property casually property casually
don't have that waiver do they have that
requirement um yes nine times out of 10
auto insurance wouldn't have that but
for follow-up visits and whatnot they
may require prior Ross and so then they
can deny for that um but you're right
for an initial accident initial you know
ass our PNC guys were here today but
they're not here now
so so because because of the story
scenario is kind of unraveling a bit
we'll just get right to the point of
what the bill is trying trying to do
which is coming in compliance with
federal law all the state uh 4D
directors you know Henry Litman our
Medicaid director all of them received a
letter back in April of last year that
says your state laws have to come into
compliance for good reason for auditing
purposes which is tsh's background as an
auditor that uh that claims cannot be
denied by virtue of not having a
priorization under the health carriers
because Medicaid as you know doesn't
even involve
if it's a Medicaid covered um benefit it
doesn't it's already pre-authorized so
that's a shield for the third party
liability company not to pay what they
should be paying as part of this so with
that because I got the aha moment the
moral to the story is always start your
presentation based upon a story I I love
this approach R hunt and I think I will
try to replicate it and I'll work harder
on a better story next time but I'm but
okay any questions for theot is that
we're trying to get TMS says we need to
be in compliance we need language that
and and of course when CMS says jump we
say how high and therefore we want to
always be in compliance so we do get our
reimbursements we do get our coverage
so perfect okay now are there any
questions from the committee members see
didn't need
it thank you okay we do have a question
will this be will this be a major Motion
[Laughter]
Picture serialized on Netflix we've got
already thank you so much okay thank
you well it was he had tried to explain
to me about the bill on the hallway and
and I said you know I think we we need a
real life real life something to to that
perfect um I I year I learned years ago
when I was on
NPR and Laura canoy said tell tell a
people want to hear a story you know
they just don't want to hear your they
want to hear a story tell them to the
folks on Science and Technology when
they get up you tell a story no we don't
want okay uh is anybody else would like
to testify on this bill
seeing none they will close the hearing
on Senate Bill three2 well this is
Senate bill so you know theoretically
theoretically these bills have already
okay
I got the right day wrong month wrong
month
I took a
very
them
e
welcome
again thank you again senator for the
record my name is Regina berzel state
senator for district 19 which
encompasses the towns of dairy Hamstead
and Windham and I am the prime sponsor
of Senate Bill
399 and uh thank you committee for
hearing uh this bill um this is the
title is relative insurance coverage for
blood testing associated with elevated
blood levels um this expands the
mandatory health insurance coverage for
blood tests associated with elevated uh
lead levels it was the intention of the
legislature when mandatory coverage for
blood tests for elevated lead levels was
adopted to include the follow-up testing
uh required without cost sharing however
um it had in some instances it hasn't
been um it hasn't been being done so the
intent of this bill is just to clarify
that intent um childhood lead poisoning
is a Public Health crisis that can cause
development delays disabilities and
other cognitive um adverse effects we
have New Hampshire has some of the
oldest housing stock in the country and
over 30,000 children live in homes with
lead based paint so and between 2017 and
2021 535 children uh tested positive for
elevated lead paint levels and then the
Senate did amend um Senate Bill 399 with
an agreement reached by all the
stakeholders to ensure that this was a
workable Bill and um the New Hampshire
Department um insurance department has
recently revised uh guidance on coverage
for blood blood Le test testing um and S
SP 399 aims to align the statute with
the the practice that the insurance
company has or the insurance department
has put forth um with that I will
questions yes re M thank you Mr chairman
thank you for taking my question I just
read through the bill um obviously if
somebody if their blood detects lead you
obviously do additional testing but if
it doesn't take it doesn't detect blood
there's nothing in here it seems to
limit how many times I you can go is
there some way to limit that well what I
did I just talked to the uh a couple of
the insurance uh reps here what this
followup is it's not a continuous um
testing but what happens is when you
have let's say a one-year-old who gets
tested and the the most uh the best way
to do it is obviously a pin prick in the
finger um sometimes that will come back
as a pulse POS false negative false
negative or false positive so what
they'll do with the followup is doing it
in a in a vein in the arm that was my
understanding from the insurance
department and most of the companies are
doing it but there are a few um that did
not realize that New Hampshire the all
of New Hampshire is considered um a lead
um because we have such old housing it's
area anybody else yes represent presel
um thank you for taking my question this
is not limited to Children
correct not no not that I no okay so and
the followup is to have an additional
test that would be conclusive is that
the purpose if if uh one was nonon
inclusive yes and the insurance company
the insurance department is here to
answer any kind of insurance questions
y thank you very much thank you cherro
callon Alex fille from the insurance
department
now you got it okay there we go um this
bill
um uh was brought to clarify an existing
mandate for coverage for blood Le lead
testing for one and two year olds um and
there uh the primary purpose um of the
clarification is to clarify two things
one that no cost sharing uh can be
imposed osed with respect to this Blood
Le testing because it's a preventive
service and number two that if the
initial screen determines an elevated
level of blood lead then um the Mandate
extends to the follow up screening
service um and when this bill was first
introduced the insurance department um
got in contact with CMS because we
suspected that the Affordable Care Act
already does
requir this same thing and we got
confirmation that no cost sharing uh is
permitted for this screening service
because it's considered preventive and
that the what is preventive includes the
follow-up screening if the initial
screening um uh shows an elevated level
of lead so we put out a bulletin to
clarify that that's what's required
under the portable Care Act and we also
helped draft an amendment to this bill
that lines it up with the
questions yes representative um if you
if you go through the the uh tests and
it determines that the person has a
elevated uh lead
poisoning uh is there does who's going
to pay for any kind of treatment is it
uh is it cover treatment for this or
anything like that yeah it's very likely
that the followup care will be cover
treatment absolutely um the main
question is um what get what is exempt
from cost sharing and what's not exempt
and so this bill makes it clear that
that initial screening is considered
preventive um and therefore no cost
sharing can can go with
representative prelli so please clarify
again it you mentioned the one and two
year olds is that what this bill is for
or yeah it deals with the Mandate that
specifically applies to um one and two
year olds and it's consistent with the
American Academy of Pediatrics
guidelines that children be tested at
age one and Age Two And this is per the
ACA um it's cons absolutely consistent
with the ACA and you know clarifies what
the obligation is one followup question
so the insur you issued a bulletin yes
so does that mean that we still need
this or it I'm not sure what um statutes
are better than
bulletins they're um shocked shocked to
hear you say that a bulletin is simply
the insurance Department's uh
announcement to the regulated entities
of how the insurance department intends
to enforce a law in this case the
portable Care Act an a statute is just a
direct statement of what the law we
don't really know who is not covering it
or um in my conversations early on with
The Advocates behind this bill um I
understand that there were some
complaints that uh came families that
came to the advocacy organization about
have having that cost sharing that they
didn't
expect and just one uh question mire
thank you what is the um
Ure its Market that this covers is it
like again yeah that's always a really
good question it's the regulated market
the fully um insured Market that state
law has jurisdiction over and it does
not include um self-funded plans that
large employers typically sponsor thank
you thank
you this is sort of deja vu because we
had a house bill uh when it came to
mammographies which is mandated ACA that
they would be not charged for and then
there was a need for a follow-up test
yes and we had the Mandate that we were
going to cover that um without co-
Insurance Cod deductible yes very
similar issue this is deja vu yes all
over all over
again similar subject but again it goes
back to that we do have some things that
are mandated that there are no
deductibles no copays because and
colonoscopy is the other one all right
any other questions to the committee
members seeing none thank you very much
thank
Ellis good afternoon members of the
committee uh my name is Molly Ellis I'm
a resident of Kean New Hampshire um
thank you for the opportunity to speak
today I'm urging you to please support
Senate Bill 39 99 I have a four-year-old
son named Walter and our house was built
about 1850 so on the advice of his
doctor we started having his lead level
tested at age one and at age two it was
was positive both times so we continued
testing um last year his lead level
spiked significantly and public health
got involved so we ended up having to do
lead abatement for our home and we're
currently having to test his levels
every three months to make sure that um
that his levels are decreasing and they
are thank goodness um but it's been a
real nightmare for our family feeling
that our own home is is poisoning our
child um initially there are no symptoms
to show that a child is being poisoned
by lead the only way that you can know
is to test um but lead poisoning can
cause cognitive um impairment stunted
growth hearing loss um impulsivity and
behavioral problems and multitude of
other of other health and behavioral
problems um the future of our state
depends on protecting our most
vulnerable
citizens um so there is a recent law
mandating that all children in New
Hampshire have their lead levels tested
at age one and Age Two however many
children are still not getting tested um
to increase access to testing for all
children um this law would would reduce
barriers to testing and make it um make
it make sure that insurance will cover
both the testing and follow-up testing
if it's required as it was for my son
because his levels were were High um so
this would help New Hampshire's most at
risk children receive the testing that
they need so again thank you for the
opportunity to speak today and I urge
you to vote a to pass for this
bill question great representative
Herbert has a question um
young kids young families um not every
young family is uh well funded and um
I'm just curious if their one of their
children
or uh um do what have happened to you um
and uh they're on Medicaid because they
can't qualify for and they can't pay for
uh you know commercial insurance or the
like I was just a my question and I
don't you don't have to answer this is
does Medicaid actually cover the um the
treatment for
lead we're getting the head shakes
yes thank you that's
much uh next up is uh Kirsten Cornell
better okay hi kirson Cornell New
Hampshire legal assistants I'm here
today uh to support this bill we've
heard a little bit about um the
disabling impact that lead poisoning can
have um and I won't spend a lot of time
talking about it because it's really not
uh you know the Crux of this bill but I
think it's important to recognize the
impact that lead poisoning has on the
New Hampshire economy overall so Studies
have been done that indicate um lead
poisoning so lead poisoning causes
lifelong disabling executive functions
disabling um for the child's entire life
so this results uh Studies have shown in
an increased need for special education
services um increased cost to the
criminal justice system increased cost
to unemployment due to
underemployment um all of these things
have a huge impact on the New Hampshire
economy so aside from wanting to protect
our youngest um State residents it's
also important to note that it has these
broad reaching
impacts um I'm a housing attorney and
the reason that this is so important in
my work directly is that we don't have
in New Hampshire what's called primary
prevention which means that there aren't
any steps that we take to ensure that
children don't get poisoned in the first
place so the way that we become aware of
lead hazards by and large in homes um is
when we identify a child as having an
elevated blood lead level and the way
that that identification happens is by
these um two uh mandatory screening so
there is an opt out since we're in New
Hampshire um and that's how we are then
able to the state is able to investigate
properties to see if there are lead
hazards in homes so this has to do with
um rented homes I think that it's
important to note that so to your point
about Medicaid Medicaid has required
this testing um I believe since the '90s
it's been um quite a long time and the
reason that uh Medicaid was doing it
first is that uh there was a
determination that kids who are on
Medicaid generally were at a higher risk
for lead poisoning so back in
2018 uh we worked on some legislation um
to require the uh private insurance
carrier to to require testing throughout
the state and and seek this um uh you
know not have there be a burden a cost
burden to parents because the amount of
housing stock in the state that is uh
built prior to when lead poison or use
of lead paint was banned is over 60% uh
and a lot of it is rental housing
um and just a small amount of lead dust
can poison a child um I think folks are
aware of the housing crisis we're facing
and this has far-reaching impacts as
well because what you're seeing is kids
who maybe would ordinarily be living in
a home that their parents owned are
renting are in a rental um situation
where they don't have as much control
over maintenance things and exposure to
hazards but they do have private
insurance so they don't qualify for the
Medicaid program that will ensure
coverage and has for for decades um so
they will rely on this private insurance
but because you know finances are tight
right now I think that people are pretty
aware of that you know there's an opt
out provision in the statute so I think
if parents are fearful that the test
won't be covered um you know they may
opt out of it and and that also has uh
far-reaching consequences for the
overall housing conditions in in the
state because you know once and Le
Hazard is identified it has to be
remediated which improves housing
conditions overall and prevents you know
the next kid who lives in that house
from being poisoned um and and this is
again particularly important during a
housing crisis because tenants are very
afraid of reporting conditions issues
for fear of being evicted because
there's really no place to go but in
this instance it's not the tenants they
aren't the ones who have to report it
the state reports it and so it takes of
the heat off of them and also requires
the landlord to provide some assistance
and relocation during the time that the
um you know the remediation work is
being done so I just you know we do
support this bill I think that this is a
particularly important moment to ensure
that these tests are covered by private
insurance companies not just Medicaid um
so that you know we don't have barriers
to testing that kids can receive the
kids who are poisoned can receive the
early intervention services that they
need right now and the you know next kid
to move into that house won't need that
help at all so I know I talked for a
while thank you very much for listening
to my
testimony another question thank you
representative Herbert has yet another
question um forgive me my ignorance but
is lead poisoning uh limited to one and
two year olds it's not so it's most
common for young children to be lead
poisoned because um up until the age of
six children don't have what's called
the blood brain barrier and please don't
ask me to explain that in any more
detail than that um and so the way that
the body absorbs the lead dust is the
the body can't uh keep it from getting
into the brain as well and it's most
common for children uh you know when
they're up until toddlers to be poisoned
because they're on the floor so unlike
the the um I think idea that people have
where you need this big piece of Chip of
paint to eat in order to become poison
like just a small amount of dust that
can be picked up with a child crawling
around the floor putting some putting
their hands in their mouth putting
everything in their mouth for anybody
who's had a child in this room um that's
when they're most at risk and and it's
important to catch you know as soon as
possible and so that's why the Mandate
the mandated testing was ages one and
two and it's possible people behind me
will know more about that but that's the
representative
burough I know this isn't part sorry
thanks for taking my question I know
this isn't part of the bill and maybe
peripheral but shouldn't we also be
doing more to ensure that home Sellers
and landlords do remediation before kids
move into these places so we don't have
to go through all this yes absolutely
okay thank we should be doing that you
asked the right person for that
question yes represent pelli I have a
question about the scope of the bill so
if you don't know the answer no problem
we'll talk about it I'm sure in
subcommittee so the way I understand it
that it's the initial test that's
inconclusive and one followup is the
scope of this bill correct so my
understanding is that yeah at both the
first and second year um appointment so
you know if a kid tests positive if they
don't test positive so let's say they
test positive and at when they're one
and they need a followup you know
they'll get screened again at two and
it's possible they'll need a follow up
then so I would assume that that would
be part of the screening process um and
it would apply in those circumstances as
well yeah I'd like to understand like
when
it okay it's all about timing in terms
of the year two years within two years
you yeah but not the ongoing after two
years it's there's something else not
this there's no mandate exctly and
Medicaid covers it and private insurance
may or may not depending on the
insurance right so well okay there was
some implication that private insurance
companies were taking wanting a co-pay
or deductible and that is clearly what's
being deleted thank you okay represent
thank you Mr chair thank you for your
testimony um I was listening to your
testimony and you mentioned that uh the
blood brain barrier is not fully
developed till the age of six could you
tell us where we could find that
information or learn more about that so
that's information that I have gained
through going to a variety of
presentations um by medical experts in
the field um I imagine that the American
Association of Pediatrics would probably
uh be able to have that
information um uh like I said I it's I
for a period of time was doing a lot of
work around lead hazards and homes and
had the opportunity to go to a lot of
presentations and that was um what was
consistently explained to me so I would
assume a medical provider a a
pediatrician someone along those lines
would be able to give you the
MD okay yes representative
ton yeah in response to representative
ammon's question I would refer you to
the Hampshire Healthy homes and lead
poisoning prevention program they have
extensive
information uh and they are more than
happy to share this I'm sure with
members of the
legislature and I can share that contact
information with you if you
want
great represent M
you this is an issue that came before
the the other committee I serve on and
would you believe that July of this year
there's a lead paint certification act
that goes into effect July 1st of 2024 I
was actually actually passed in I did
just have to look it up but 2018 but it
came up because we were modifying the
real estate
form uh so effect of July of this year
there's a for I think it's just new
construction as I quickly read it uh for
rentals and daycare there's a new lead
paint certification and that's as much
as I could glean quickly but it's it's
right on point for this and if just now
going into effect six years after
Passage it's called a would you believe
yeah I
just somewhere else was that a question
yes but maybe you maybe you know more
about it actually than I could just um I
I it does apply only to uh new
construction uh everything you said
about it is about the extent to which I
I'm familiar with it but um
unfortunately no it doesn't require any
work to be done on uh homes that were
previously built or or daycare
facilities and the reason that's
unfortunate is that the use of lead
paint was band until 1978 and until 1950
it was nearly ubiquitous so it's
everywhere um and it's it's great that
there's a certificate going forward you
can't really use it now anyway but yeah
let's do everything we can um I hope
that in the future we'll be able to to
get some work done on the older homes
too great thank you very much thank
you uh
Heidi
trarco representing
clf oh I know this this
is
uh tell us what it
is good afternoon we met before Heidi
Mar with the conservation law CF I
didn't know if you wanted I knew it to
get there if you wanted me to uh thank
you for hearing my testimony I'll keep
it brief because um um working with
other Le partners and you just heard
some other testimonies so um we're all
working kind of in in concert to get
this bill passed um we urge the
committee to vote a to pass as the
committee heard as a result of SB 248 in
2018 the state required all one and two
yearolds to be tested for blood lead
levels and we have that data now um and
the DHHS puts out a data brief what that
has all of that evidence and you can
look it up and see all the evidence of
lead poisoning in the state um in 2022
8816 children in New Hampshire were
poisoned by lead so this is a really
prevalent problem in our state and it's
something that we know we know what the
problem is we know where the science is
and we know how to um address it and how
to prevent it and so um we look forward
to legislation working to prevent lead
poisoning in the future this bill is to
fix a gap in the um just in the
insurance coverage for that testing for
the one and two year olds and so um it
was always the intent that the insurance
would cover for that testing and this
bill just clarifies that and uh we urge
the committee to vote ought to
pass
great thank you very much thank
Futures thank you Mr chairman honorable
members of the committee this is my
first time before you this year I'm
pinch hitting for one of my colleagues
Jake Barry who I'm sure that you have
seen before um I am happy to share new
futur position on this particular piece
of legislation um we worked with the
original group of stakeholders back in
2018 around the universal testing of um
childhood Le levels uh and at that time
we have the legislative history as well
as our own notes that it was fully the
intent of this legislature to ensure the
full cost and coverage um of children
when they were being if they were
privately insured for those tests
unfortunately new Futures is also the
kids count Organization for the State of
New Hampshire um and we received some
anecdotal information from some of our
Advocates and Community Partners that
the universal coverage was not actually
happening um we also looked at the data
and saw between after the law was passed
in 2018 we saw a spike in the number of
kids that were being tested as you would
presume when there's a universal testing
requirement however after covid it
dropped by 25 % and we were really
scratching our heads as to what was
happening some of it was covid related
um but that wasn't the entire story and
we started to receive more and more
examples of cost sharing that was being
passed on to parents in conflict with
what the underlying intent of the
legislature was in
2018 um we also just want to reiterate
the points that were made by some of our
other colleagues that spoke on behalf of
the bill prior that there are currently
32,000 kids in this state who are living
in homes where there are known Le
hazards um this bill is a necessary
statutory clarification so that we can
close the gap that currently exists
while the insurance department did Issue
a bulletin we we do believe that
statutory clarification would be
important in this particular
case um let me see if there's anything
else that I want to share that hasn't
already been
said again it just reaffirms the intent
of the 2018 legislation and provides the
needed clarification so I'm happy to
answer any questions that folks may have
um but that is the experience of new
Futures and the folks that we work with
in the
community great thank you nice to see
you again thank
you okay anybody else would like to
weigh
in seeing none we'll close the public
hearing
uh ledge Etc just send it to house
Commerce that'll that'll go to everybody
specifically about the blood brain
barrier not fully developed by six years
of age that's that's what he wanted to
accurate well that's what I'm looking
for he wants to know how they came he
settled on Sixx six years of age there's
no blood brain barrier that seems crazy
it well I'd like to see a source that's
here
C
thank
he
I
k
already
l
thanks for
asking kind
of next few days
too okay we'll get going here open up
the public Hearing in Senate Bill 353
and hear from the prime sponsor Senator
Waters good afternoon
Senator uh thank you Mr chairman members
of the committee I'm Senator David
Waters from uh District 4 uh introducing
Senate Bill 353 relative to insurance
coverage for autism spectrum disorder
and down syndrome as you can see from
the language of the bill it changes a
couple of um definitions in a sense
brings them up to date where the most uh
Rec recent desk manual is uh so we have
autism spectrum disorder and including
uh Down syndrome in a definitional part
um and then the heart of the bill is the
availability then due to these new def
definitions of um coverage for uh
treatment in particular as you'll hear
from The Advocates who will follow me
and some from healthc Care Professionals
um we're particularly talking about
applied behavor behavioral
analysis um and uh this uh therapy for
those with autism and down syndrome has
been demonstrated as one letter we had
in the Senate from a physician is a kind
of gold standard for helpful treatment
uh here um so that that that's the uh
essential part of this I think we're
going to hear from some families and
Advocates as to how this kind of therapy
has has helped um and I will leave more
of that medical uh discussion to the
folks who follow I did want to say a
little bit because here we are in in
Commerce and of course the insurance
costs and other things are will be of
concern um to you and as you will see
that uh the the bill will have no
fisical impact this year and physcal
note suggests that it's rather it's
somewhat indeterminant as to how many
more cases will come um in the following
years and potentially have some kind of
cost or or impact um if it helps uh in
the Senate hearing when um there was a
question about well how many people
might you know be covered by this and
there is a a physician down in
Massachusetts who is a kind of go-to
person and for Massachusetts about 80
people and that would translate in terms
of population to maybe 14 up here um so
um yes you know there is little
uncertainty over the costs and the
insurance impacts but um I I do think
you're going to see um the benefits that
this might provide to families and uh it
explains why after the hearing there was
such um strong strong bipartisan support
in the Senate as you can see from the
folks who are um lined up here and you
know a lot of us have personal stories
um uh with autism and and Down Down
Syndrome from from family members and uh
I think we know the extraordinary
progress that a caring Society like ours
has made towards uh making sure that
families get their help so people can
leave uh leave lead full and productive
lives um as much as much as possible and
get the kind of help so um this I think
this is a a very good step forward for
the state to be able to cover uh ABA and
that's why the bill is here and Mr
chairman I think questions for me would
uh very quickly get beyond what I can
meaningfully offer so I I would be happy
to take any but I think what you're
going to hear from the folks behind me
who have very deep experience on the
personal and medical side of this would
spent okay thank
you all right
um so I have a lot of cards
here do we have uh does anybody here an
expert on this issue or can tell us tell
helpful great I I think that's me today
okay great what is your thank you we
have a lot of first today in this
hearing so what is your name uh my name
is Amy Ray I'm from Derry New hampsh
okay great hi
John um I wasn't sure if somebody from
the board of New Hampshire ABA was going
to be here or not but I think that's
going to be me today T you're it okay
so again uh am I would you like me to
start uh tell us why we need to pass
this bill okay that'll be great um I'm
here to advocate for you to support uh
Senate Bill 353 to broaden insurance
coverage for Applied Behavior Analysis
to include people with Down
Syndrome uh ABA therapy applied Behavior
Analysis therapy is a scientific
evidence-based therapy that has been in
effect for the last 60 years or
so um I'm shaking a little bit I haven't
done this since Connor's
[Music]
[Laughter]
law um I'm a parent of a child with
autism who has benefited from ABA
therapy he's now 16 he's had ABA therapy
for 12 of the last 16 years it was ped
um the year Connor's law was passed was
the Year my son was diagnosed with
autism I'm also a bcba and what that
means is I'm a board certified behavior
analyst and what that means is I have a
master's degree in education
and I also had 1500 hours of supervised
experience I've been in the field for 24
years and I've been certified for 16
years uh someone asked me how many
people I've worked with and I'm going to
go with
hundreds I honestly don't know um but I
wanted to share with you a little bit
about the people that I've worked with
um I've worked with teenagers with Down
Syndrome Who as a result of ABA
intervention have gone on to become
volunteers and have paid employment and
become productive members of
society I have worked recently with
Elementary age children who as a result
of ABA intervention have been able to
stay in the general education setting
and do not need substantially separate
or special education placements so
that's that's really exciting that
children with Down Syndrome benefit will
benefit just like children with autism
do from ABA
therapy I have also consulted and met
with families who have loved ones with
Down Syndrome unfortunately due to not
having ABA therapy coverage through
their insurance I was not able to help
them I've seen these families struggle
with communication social skills
maladaptive behaviors that all could be
therapy please consider all these things
that I have shared with you and that you
could change lives for those with Down
Syndrome for less than 20 cents per
policy year oop I skipped apart sorry um
these children with ABA may also
struggle with toilet tra toilet training
feeding and dressing skills learning how
to speak or to be understood by others
and how to have a back and forth
conversation with a peer or how to
follow a daily schedule all these
symptoms that a child with Down Syndrome
may have may be remediated by ABA so
please support Senate Bill 353 to
broaden insurance coverage for ABA to
include people with Down Syndrome thank
you
okay you do have questions represent
Ammon thank you Mr chair thank you for
your testimony you did great oh thanks
um I just have a question on uh line
three of the bill it's uh letter h i
I'll just it's a strike out the bill
Strikes Out pervasive developmental
disorder or Autism so it strikes that
out and it changes it to autism spectrum
disorder y um is that is that an
outdated term why why what are we
striking out and what are we um I I
didn't write the bill but I can share
with you what I know medically pervasive
developmental disorder what what is that
yeah so before um in the dsm5 the
diagnostic statistic manual it when this
was first um it was first called pddn
pervasive development disorder and then
autism spectrum disorder and then
Aspergers and so what they did with the
dsm5 as they took it and just called it
autism spectrum disorder and took out
the PDD part and the asp burer
part just follow father question you may
inquire so the the autism spectrum
disorder what percentage of children
roughly would fall into that Spectrum
just curious about the numbers um right
now 1 in 36 as of a couple months
ago okay representative
prelli thank you for your testimony
today can can you please explain a
little bit more about what exactly ABA
therapy or treat is and if you know
anything related to the costs associated
with it I don't know what the treatment
would entail okay all right I'm going to
do my best I'm sweating it out
here um well aba therapy is to help
people with things that are socially
significant you know so activities of
daily living communication social skills
and what that involves is someone like
myself writing a treatment plan so I
might meet with a family or with a
student and find out what some things
that they would like to see and what are
some things they that you would like to
decrease um often children with
disabilities have behaviors um that are
that are a result of having a lack of
communication skills so what I would do
is I would train somebody like a direct
therapist or a registered Behavior
technician and they're just someone that
I would train on how to carry out that
treatment plan so I would teach them you
know how to teach them um I guess Xander
here learned how to brush his teeth you
know or how to stop when someone says
stop a lot of times we help people with
safety and so we come in the home
anywhere from 10 to 40 hours a week or
in a clinic based setting and help
remediate those symptoms of their
disability did I answer all the
questions okay all
right the cost your your mic on say that
I'm sorry yes thank you so I so it's uh
it's oneon-one counseling yes perhaps y
with someone that can teach the skills
based on your plan and it could be
something that is minimal or um you know
very intensive that's correct so do you
happen to know what how the costs are
calculated I don't know right now I
don't know the answer to that maybe
somebody else does here okay thank you
so how are you paid who who pays you so
I currently work for a school district
so I'm working with students right now
but for years or 22 years I worked in
home clinic and community based settings
so excuse me so each of these kids have
an IEP and you're the one who's
handling okay so right now this is all
being paid by the school district for
the last two years in my position the
previous 20 years I worked for an agency
for the state for agency of the state
and that was paid under Medicare a uh
for the adults yes other than that I did
insurance-based Home Services you know
like Harvard Pilgrim Blue Cross so some
insurance companies do pay for it y okay
so this this legislation is that there
are some insurance companies are not
paying for it they do for autism but not
yet for Downs okay so they're only doing
in the autism okay now we're clarifying
it's a spectrum rather than and I and
yes I think we're up to DSM 9 now or
something I'm not
sure we moved Along on DSM so generally
in terms of
uh where this is often is being applied
is um is in the school in this the IEPs
in the school environment um in the
school environment yes but most of what
children need is through early
intervention so they need the insurance
based coverage and that's what's being
asked for here today right so I guess
what I'm trying to so so this is just
before schools then it could be before
school it could be during school it
could be after I'm saying it could be
right so the Guess The $64,000 Question
is um are we trying to get insurance
companies to pay for something that
schools are now paying for no this is a
medical service it's a com it's a it's a
medical service not an educational
service not to be confused on the IEP
and what's going on in the classroom
yeah it's completely
separate okay thank you now
representative perz sorry didn't mean to
interrupt you Mr chair um my question is
we had a question about the costs
involved in this what are the societal
costs of not providing this kind of care
for for children with Down syndrome and
that might be tough to to
answer I I'll do my best I wasn't quite
ready and prepared for this as a parent
I I would like
to what's that okay yeah as a parent
would be good answer too oh man um just
we you know we got rid of Institutions
for a reason you know um children who do
not access just safety things such as
when to stop and when to go um just
potty training alone you know there
there are children who are six seven
eight go on to adulthood unfortunately
are not potty trained um the aggressive
behaviors the safety behaviors it
results in in you know going back to you
know what would be group hones or
residential settings which obviously I
know what the cost is that's hundreds of
thousands of dollars for when children
don't get these types of services that
they
much representative
spear uh you made a comment very quickly
in passing that the cost was 20 cents
per member or 20 cents per person or
something like that for the uh an
estimate for the insurance what was that
based on um I'm going to let somebody
else speak to that that was information
that was given to me that I asked for I
don't I don't know where the math
okay well represent
woles thank you Mr chair and thank you
for testifying do you happen to know how
many ABA therapists there are throughout
the
state um well we have about 400 board
certified Behavior analysts we do not
have enough to go
around um I don't know how many
technicians we have follow up for the
question
thank you so you had mentioned earlier
that you can also train others to do
this therapy if needed or is that common
or yeah usually the bcba is um I guess
you would say like a doctor is to a
nurse or a medical assistant so the bcba
is the one that comes up with a plan and
then they train the technician or the
direct therapist on how how to carry out
or like a teacher to a pair professional
okay so kind of like a Frontline worker
MH
okay thank you very much you did a great
job thanks are you William Walker okay
you're
next thank you chairman and me members
of the committee for my considering my
testimony today appreciate it my name is
Will Walker I live in Hollis New
Hampshire with my wife and my
25-year-old son who has autism um please
support s sp353 uh to say broaden
insurance coverage for Applied Behavior
Analysis for people down syndrome and I
really want to clarify we we're talking
about broadening insurance coverage to
include people with Down Syndrome uh the
the talk about autism spectrum disorder
and all that that's clarifying and
updating language in the existing law
okay so it's not adding anything for
people without autism people with Autism
already have the insurance coverage just
asking for including people with Down
Syndrome um I am the legislative liaison
for gateways Community Services out in
aswa uh it's one of the 10 area agencies
in the State uh that uh enables services
for people with developmental
disabilities and acquired brain
disorders as a legislative liaison and
the I'm active Statewide and I also lead
a group of approximately 280 families in
my area to ADV advocate for appropriate
policy that enables people with
developmental disabilities and acquired
brain disorders to live full inclusive
and productive lives you're going to
hear very compelling testimony today
okay and I could give you
similar compelling testimony about the
impact of ABA that it had on my son and
my life okay I can also talk about
research that has been done that says
how effective uh ABA is for people with
Down Syndrome okay so NIH NIH studies
peer-reviewed um uh research that
demonstrates ABA is very very compelling
and and and effective treatment for
people with Down Syndrome but I'm not
going to do that okay well maybe I just
did but I'm not going to do that I'm
going to talk about why this is a
fiscally responsible thing to do in
Massachusetts we have House Bill 1084
and Senate Bill
617 okay these bills have been in the
Massachusetts legislature for a while
and they're very similar to what we're
asking for today and the general
Massachusetts General law requires an
estimate of a Bill's fiscal impact as
well as a review of the efficacy of the
therapy okay so Massachusetts has done
this already and they they contracted
with Barry Dunn a National Services form
firm to do this study and I'm going to
just point out one they support the
efficacy of the therapy okay so it is it
is a reasonable and very good therapy
for people with Down syndrome and you'll
hear more about how it helps people but
the other thing in the barry dun report
and I'm the one that came up with the 20
cents all right so the Barry dun report
said the additional cost per member
would be between 0.10
0.0025% and they put a dollar figure on
that and if you add if you multiply that
out it it adds up to about 18 cents per
member per year in the worst case okay
so it's not a lot of money so what does
18 cents give give you right what's the
return on investment of 18 cents for a
single individual it can save tens of
thousands of dollars in medical costs
due to accidents caused by maladaptive
behaviors you can also argue that it can
be a life saving therapy it can increase
in individual's in Independence and
reduce the cost of care over their
entire lifetime okay they don't need a
care provider to help them through this
this can help really improve behaviors
and reduce the cost of care over their
life um in school children okay it can
enable a a child to be in a inclusive
environment included in the classroom
resulting in a reduction in the cost of
supports needed for them in in the
classroom it can enable the individual
to get a job it can enable the
individual's families to go back to work
okay so this is what we're we're looking
at right for 18 cents per member per
year we're looking at this entire
benefit on society so that I think the
sooner we support SP sp353 the sooner
our state will benefit so thank you for
for considering my testimony please
support SP
sp353 uh it'll help families obtain
insurance coverage for ABA for their
loved ones with down Sy
and it not only makes sense from
personal standpoint but it's also the
fiscally responsible thing to do for our
wonderful State of New Hampshire thank
you so uh before I take a question I you
say this has been in front of the
Massachusetts legislature for a couple
of years yeah what what happens is they
somebody brought a bill forward and
Massachusetts General Law requires a
study to be done it took it took time
for that study to be put in place when
did that study get done it was done in
August
2023 okay so the bills are in the final
throws of being approved in
Massachusetts okay that's why I was
trying to figure this out we we have a
similar statute that we can do a
financial analysis okay so okay
representative burrow thanks for taking
my question I just want to confirm that
you're saying that this bill would also
impact adults with Down Syndrome PTSD
PTSD okay I don't know if I don't know
what's going on over so in the in the
existing law right it says chronic PTSD
but that's not an addition from this
bill this bill is just really adding
correct that's already in the
statute I wasn't but exactly you what
she she was asking is thank you I
thought I was going nuts so the the the
therapy in The Spill would also impact
adult adults with it could potentially
potentially I mean t typically what you
would see is early intervention and
inhome supports
uh those those Medicaid uh thing people
on those waivers they cannot get the
coverage through Medicaid and so what
they would do is go to their private
private insurance company for this
coverage and we're seeing people denied
right right now just a follow because
I'm suppos trying to understand I'm I'm
I'm thinking about a friend who has an
adult child with autism and uh I worry
about what's going to happen to him when
she's no longer around so he's I think
he's 27 now so he would still be able to
get services through this is it would be
if you approve this bill and and it goes
through it broadens insurance coverage
for people with Down Syndrome okay so
anybody right perfect okay thank you so
much and you mentioned you have a son
yourself I have a son who's 25 years old
we uh saw him go through ABA okay he has
autism okay and uh I I just how do I put
this imagine that you're you're in pain
or something's really really bothering
you and you can't communicate it you
have no way of expressing that how do
you how would you behave right you you
can do things in a very unpredictable
way you could do self harm you could run
out into the street or whatever and what
ABA helped my son do right with that
type of thing is be able to communicate
and that just that ability to be able to
express something sure diffuses a lot of
the
stress so does you still use the service
or that
he got he got cured from that that issue
somehow it's not a lifelong therapy no I
mean I I would think that that's where
she was going with the question which is
worrying that it could be something that
would be unending I I don't I don't
believe it's unending I mean um but when
we talk about adults there may be people
that have been denied insurance coverage
but but it could be applicable for them
right so is any you said massachus has
anybody talked about um how long you
would have it or you Ser for instance um
over the years one of our big issues
with mental health and we actually had
limits to how many visits you can get
you know in terms of what was medically
necessary so has any state ever done
that with this autism subject I don't
know about limit limiting the therapy I
mean there's only so many so many hours
in a week but um I think we're talking
about lifetime yeah I'm trying to think
on thank you a Aba for him was uh in his
school years and then when he
transitioned to adulthood uh we didn't
see the need to continue the therapy
okay so and you were talking about how
this therapy has been proven to be
effective and has you know has um
clinically based you know tests and
showing that it really helped is there
any settings on how long something this
care can be offered offered or how long
it should be offered or or any you know
terms of limits I guess that you in
terms of getting to this question you
mean in your mind what why would you
want to set any limits but that when it
comes to health insurance one of the
things that it's always an issue is that
we the idea is to get you cured you know
get you healthy and then then you don't
need it anymore so what is in terms of
to me I mean I I guess it's my own
Nativity but but a Down syndrome person
is is down forever so how in terms of
we're going to just focus in like mental
health that we're going to focus in on
certain behavior and address that
behavior and then once that behavior has
been uh I don't know if it's been cured
but it's remediated then then
theoretically the coverage could be over
yeah I I can't speak in general terms on
this Amy would be the right person to
ask about this um I can say for my son
he has autism for his entire life okay
he's not cured um and we saw that uh ABA
was very helpful and you reach a point
where you say it's it's it's run its
course right great thank you okay any
other questions yes question I had I
worked in the school district for a
number of years working with Spectrum
disordered children and I was wondering
a lot of times what we would have to do
is is particularly if we were working
under a counselor um that we would be
able to bill for our hours would this
allow School District to build for hours
when they were you doing certain um
Counseling Services with their children
so may I ask any questions does do
school districts for Direct Services yes
you can Med when a bcba provides a
direct
service but not private not private yeah
not private we wouldn't be able to
private okay
thank great thank you very much thank
you very much okay um I have a bunch of
cards here people want to want to speak
for the bill so but before I do that
we'll just have someone who is actually
in opposition to the
bill
there so what is our cautionary tale
here yes good afternoon um Mr chairman
and members of the committee for the
record my name is Heidi croll I work at
Gallagher Calahan and Garrell and I'm
here today representing a hip which is
America's health insurance plans um so
we just wanted to flag um a couple of
things with this bill um one is uh the
effective date so the effective date um
is upon passage usually with mandates we
have them be effective the first of the
year to sync up with the plan year um so
that's one of our concerns um another
concern we have is that um when you look
at this bill in terms of um I'm looking
at line 13 repeal um it's um requesting
to repeal RSA 417 E2 Roman 3 relative to
coverage limits however that um that
section was actually repealed already in
um 2022 by
sb373 um so now um what this bill would
repeal
is
um a section that currently reads as
follow follows and I don't think this is
the intent of the advocates for this
bill um they would now be repealing a
section that reads nothing in this
section shall be construed to affect any
obligation by a school district or the
state of New Hampshire to provide
services to an individual under an
individualized family service plan for
an individualized education program as
required under the federal individuals
with disabilities Education Act the
state children's health insurance
program um Etc I don't think that The
Advocates um really want to be repealing
um that provision of law
um the uh as I said the provision that
used to be Roman 3 um relative to limits
has already been repealed so whoever
drafted this piece of legislation I
think looked at an old version of the
statute
so
um two other points I was just going to
make um one um this again only applies
to the fully insured Market um not the
self-funded market um it would apply to
both the individual and the employer
groups but again only fully insured
which is approximately 28% of the market
so this would not apply to self-funded
plans which um uh make up about 34% of
the market so I think people's
expectations just need to be um set
appropriately that um there will still
be um uh people who are under those
plans who are not going to have coverage
under this particular statute um and the
final thing I was going to say um you
know ultimately this is a legislative
decision um at least one of the plans
provided got uh information to me that
um that they have found that there is
not enough clinical evidence to show
that ABA is an effective treatment for
individuals with Down Syndrome um their
BH team only found two studies that
support that um and requiring um
coverage of ABA for individuals with
Down Syndrome could also exacerbate the
existing access um issues to Aba um due
to as you heard earlier provider
shortages so if we're um it's just
something to be aware of if you're
expanding the population um who is
eligible for ABA Services um uh again it
you know I guess maybe there's um not
the substantial body of clinical
evidence that I guess there is for um
the autis autism spectrum disorder um
and just making folks aware that it
could um make access even more
challenging because you'd be adding more
people eligible without increasing the
provider um supply side if you
will Network adequacy
yes well yeah just the fact that the
providers are just not there in the
state but that kind of begs the question
is this a new mandate and so therefore
the state has to pay for it when it
comes to the
marketplace I guess I look at the
insurance department that no I don't
have an answer because just expanding a
law that already on the
books
okay okay right there already bet it's
already required right okay just it just
because we're
clarifying adding it's not adding a new
category it's it's a statute that are
exists okay all right cool
um any questions I get so when this
thing got
repealed s we do we do that we did that
repeal apparently it's it was a um well
actually um I'm
looking um least in the Senate it was
the Health and Human Services committee
um it was a Senate bill it was Senate
Bill
373 um it was approved on July 25th of
202 2 and it became effective on
2022 so okay so I think whoever drafted
the bill the limits is really what we're
talking about in terms of a has age
limits and it has dollar amounts and had
some some guard rails as you might call
them okay yes representative Herbert um
I didn't hear that gentleman's remark as
to the the additional
we'll we'll invite the insurance
department to come up next here to
you okay tag who wants to come up and
pieces yeah
oh look what we have here I didn't see
commissioner I should have hit
better okay so we the two questions we
have obviously is uh that paragraph that
got repealed and and what was the basis
around feeling that we didn't need any
guard rails around that and does it
change now that we're adding Down
syndrome to the list which which then we
just heard is that some insurance
companies that the efficacy of care
coverage for Down syndrome is in
question I'm going to start with the
easy one which is the we brought a bill
in 2022 to repeal the limits because the
mental health parity act prohibited us
from having those limits okay so we were
unable to enforce those
limits um even with that book that law
on the books so we came to the
legislature and said we need to remove
it so that was done quickly and that
would apply we can't add them back the
same issue applies we have mental health
generally so that is a I I would view
that as a technical flaw in the bill
that should be I think it should be
removed or um just will they just be
removed line three yes there's no need
to repeal that just remove line three
correct and then change the effective
dat to U January
1st okay so those are good but how about
this efficacy
issue well I mean that's obviously
something that we don't weigh in on
those are for doctors and medical
professionals to make those
determinations and ultimately it's well
it's medical directors of the you might
want to pull the mic a little bit closer
but that's up to the medical director of
the health insurance company that's
right that's it it is a determination
for the medical director of the carrier
to get together with the physician that
is treating the patient and come to an
agreement on what the most
appropriate type of care or treatment is
that's not something that we get
involved with that's a medical necessity
determination we're not qualified to
weigh in on those matters well let's say
if there's a disagreement then it would
go to the grievance ultimately it could
go to an external review that's right
external review to decide whether the
the protocol was appropriate or not
that's
right
okay thank you all thank you very much
thank you okay now we got those out of
the
way okay so I can all ask everyone
because there's a pile of cards here and
I know you all would anxiously wanted to
come and share with us and we do want to
hear from you um all I can ask is please
don't repeat what someone else said if
you got a unique story that what we
I I did it hi thank you for having me
today to speak um my name is Rebecca
Bergman I live in Dober New Hampshire I
a mom to three children I've also been a
foster parent for over 6 years caring
for children ages 0 to 14 with varying
needs I am on the foster care advisory
Advisory board for DCF and a former
board member of the New Hampshire Foster
and adoptive parent Association I care
deeply about the needs of children in
our state I speak before you today as a
parent and advocate for children
including those with Down Syndrome I'm
here to wholeheartedly support SB 353 a
bill that aims to expand insurance
coverage for ABA for those with Down
Syndrome I have experienced F firsthand
the transformation and power of ABA the
therapy in the lives of children with
Down Syndrome thanks to the targeted
interventions provided by ABA therapists
my 7-year-old son Asher is good friends
with Xander who is a six-year-old boy
with Down Syndrome since starting ABA
I've seen huge changes in Xander's
communication with my son and others and
his friend group his ability to
understand social situations and his
ability to interact in group situations
such as kicking the soccer ball in an
age appropriate way which is something
they enjoy doing together one of the
most significant challenges we face is
the current qualification criteria for
ABA Services which often rely on a
diagnosis based approach while this
approach is suitable for many it does
not always consider the individual needs
of children with Down Syndrome last
summer my oldest son JJ was diagnosed
with level one autism and ADHD his
neuropsychologist suggested several
supports including OT and counseling but
they did not suggest ABA based on his
individual needs even though he
qualifies based on his diagnosis she did
not find it necessary children with Down
Syndrome can have complex and diverse
needs that may exceed those of children
with certain categories of autism it's
essential that we adopt a needs-based
approach for qualifications for ABA
Services ensuring that all children can
benefit from the therapy and have access
to it and I know money has obviously
been a big part of the conversation so I
know there's others like me who aren't
having access to this bill even though
they could so not all of us are using
that therapy so hopefully that would
make room for others that need it um so
I urge you to support sp353 and help
make ABA therapy more more accessible to
individuals with Down Syndrome by doing
so we can make a meaningful difference
in the lives of these families and the
individuals thanks thank you for
considering that's excellent thank you
very much
hi my name is Calvin
Watson friend with Asher bman and Xander
Foster Xander is a Kind and Generous
friend when he sees me he always gives
me a hug I want Xander to have ABA
therapy so he can do lemonade dance
together and he can be safe and not run
the road like he used
to now i' like to spend time theander he
was not listening before now he's doing
great he was strong he is strong and has
a loving heart and soul he loves me and
my friends he is great and fun I love
him he and he is good helpful and
Watson hi my name is June and I'm no
Xander since the day who was born Xander
is really silly and fun to be around I
like to jump on the trampoline with him
and catch frogs in the woods we used to
have to ask Megan what Xander was trying
to say but now he can talk a lot more
and we know what he is saying without
him getting
frustrated my brother who is Xander's
age and I get to do a lot of stuff by
ourselves but Xander usually needs a
grown up with him it would be really
great if he could learn to do more stuff
that the rest of us can do and I think
ABA therapy could help with
that excellent thank you very
much hang you want I just want to say
something to the kids uh think 3 seconds
okay well three seconds she has
something she wants to say I just want I
just want to say to both of your
children that you're both really kind
and caring people and I really and you
made me cry which I don't
cheslock hi um thank you um chairman
hunt and members of the House Commerce
and consumer affairs committee my name
is Kaylee cheslock and I live in Dover
um I'm asking you to support SB 353 to
broaden insurance cover coverage for ABA
to include people with Down Syndrome I'm
in favor of this bill because I have the
privilege of knowing Xander Foster and
um I I just have the desire to see him
Thrive I've seen the benefits of ABA
therapy in his life with the
socialization and ability to stay safe
um I've been there in times when Xander
has run away or done things that are
scary and um I have seen that ABA
therapy has helped him to stay safe and
has reduced the risk of injury to him
and those around him which I do believe
I know that you're all considering costs
and this will reduce medical costs in
the long term just for the care that he
needs um I have my two oldest children
with me here today um and I just wanted
to read um you know just talking about
the benefits and and you heard June and
Calvin say that they've seen changes in
Xander and um my girls have two um
Ariana is 9 years old and she says that
she loves Xander and she loves when he
hugs her and says her name and ABA
therapy has helped Xander to be able to
say her name and understand what she's
saying and like see who is six says um
that ABA therapy has um helped Xander
learn to be safe and that she wants
Xander to be safe um so thank you for
considering my testimony and the
testimony of my daughters and I urge you
to support s SP 353 thank you great
thank
Bon
do hi there for the record my name is
Lisa Bodwin strategies for disability
Equity I am a Disability Policy
professional and I'm also the parent of
a young man with Down Syndrome he is 28
and he lives on his own and he completed
high school with a real high school
diploma and ABA was one of the um
therapies that he received as a very
young child um that our family had to
privately pay for because we were denied
coverage so um just have a a couple of
other small policy notes um just to
differentiate when children with IEPs
who are in school who get ABA they're
getting it covered through Medicaid it's
the Medicaid to school programs so this
bill will not impact students in who are
receiving services in their school
buildings uh I also wanted to emphasize
will Walker's Point the net benefits
across the lifespan will specifically
serve the self-interest of the State of
New Hampshire because of if youngsters
received ABA therapy they are better
staged to have jobs as adults to be
contributing civic-minded engaged
citizens which is what we all want we
want everyone to have an equal footing
but most importantly to the state of New
Hampshire across the
lifespan Medicaid long-term supports and
services costs will deliver a will be
lowered because if if
individuals um have more
Independence and
self-reliance due to receiving the
supports and services that they need to
be staged for success as adults that
means fewer Medicaid dollars need to be
services and that's all I have this the
the stories that um you are hearing are
compelling and um I hope you will
support this
still thank you very much for your
testimony I didn't realize it was a
French
name
Foster you come after
me um hi um I'd like to thank the chair
in the committee for the opportunity to
speak my name is is Megan Foster I live
in Dober New Hampshire and I'm asking
you to support SB 353 to broaden
insurance coverage for Applied
behavioral analysis to include people
with Down
Syndrome I am a mom to Xander a
six-year-old boy with Down syndrome and
last summer we had the scare of Our
Lives when Xander loped from summer camp
and was gone for about an hour in an
area surrounded by water later in the
month he swallowed a number of
acetaminophen tablets and had to be
hospitalized and treated at Mass General
Hospital we immediately started
researching behavioral interventions I'm
a registered nurse by trade and so
evidence-based practice is incredibly
important to me during the research we
came across evidence regarding the
effectiveness of ABA with individuals
with Down syndrome and had multiple
assessments done on Xander and the
providers who knew Xander best decided
that the interventions offered by ABA
ABA could address not only the major
safety concerns that we had but many of
the personal hygiene and self-help
skills that would help protect Xander's
personhood his dignity and health every
day when applying for a for coverage for
the ABA assessment by our insurance it
took over eight months to process
because Xander didn't have an Autism
diagnosis and believe me we tried that
route we tried to get him an Autism
diagnosis he doesn't have
autism every neuros pych eval said no no
shortly after beginning Services we
heard that our insurance again denied
coverage even though the assessment had
said that he could benefit from ABA
Services because he did not have an
Autism diagnosis despite research
medical necessity is deemed both by
Xander's primary care doctor and an
expert in the health care of individuals
of with Down syndrome and documented
progress that these Services had been
effective these things didn't matter to
the insurance company because the only
measure they relied on was the law
stating that he it only needed to be
covered for individuals with autism
Xander has continued AB therapy after
many phone calls to senators and many
hours on the phone with insurance
companies he's made strides in
participating in safe and health
promoting behaviors that will serve as
prevention for major health problems
later in life he's acquiring skills and
Independence through ABA which will
serve to reduce the cost burden for
caring for him in the future this is the
case for many individuals like him
Xander has Medicaid and his
acetaminophen overdose alone cost tens
of thousands of dollars prior to
beginning ABA therapy Xander was unable
to tolerate toothbrushing at all he had
to undergo anesthesia for a cleaning in
a cavity fill that cost over $10,000
again C covered by Medicaid but after
repeated exposure and utilizing expert
shaping skills for his negative
behaviors he can brush his own teeth and
tolerate toothbrushing by his
parents he hasn't have a had a cavity
since Medicaid also currently pays for
Xander's incontinence supplies but with
ABA he has demonstrated moderate success
another cost that which predicts another
cost that will be relieved with
continued
Ava thinking back to the beginning of my
testimony when I shared about Alexander
loping in the worst case scenario had
Xander been hurt or drowned there would
have been enormous Financial cost to the
emergency services not to mention the
lasting financial and emotional cost
that would have been born to the town
and organizations involved prior to Aba
we were avoiding and narrowly missing
situations like this every single day
now Xander stops when he's told to and
understands the need to stay with adults
in unsafe situations as a mother seeing
Xander be more successful in interacting
with his peer Group which you heard
about accessing education with the tools
that he's built through ABA therapy he
wouldn't even stay in the classroom
before ABA I'm grateful for the ways
that this has created systems in our
home that help us navigate caring for
Xander in ways that preserve his safety
personhood dignity and health for
reference I've included testimonies for
the Massachusetts House Bill 10 1084
which is like this proposal in SB 353
353 for from the for most experts in
Down syndrome Dr Brian scottco of
Massachusetts General Hospital Angela
Lombardo of the Massachusetts Down
syndrome Congress as well as the doctors
at Boston Children's Hospital thank you
chairman hunt and members of the
Commerce and consumer affairs committee
for considering my testimony I urge you
to support SB 353 to decrease future
costs associated with supporting
individuals who have developmental
disabilities like down syndrome this
will help Xander live a safe more
independent inclusive and productive
life thank you thank you very much any
questions I think they're all questioned
out
Graham good afternoon chairman hunt and
committee members thank you for hearing
Our Testimony my name is Tim Graham I
live and work in ex New Hampshire and uh
I uh I'm not going to repeat uh a lot of
what's already been said here today but
uh suffice to say that uh as a as a
grandparent of Xander I've witnessed
some of what ABA has already done for
him and I uh I fully support and ask you
to support SB
353 uh to help pass this bill I'm quite
nervous and I will um I'm just I'm just
going to leave it with thank you very
much for putting this committee together
and thank you very much for listening I
hope you support the Bill thank you fair
enough thank you very much I'll give you
testimony and we love to have that
testimony when you get home you can
too
in um I
then
and oh the
way Xander wanted you to know the five
things that he thought were most
important around what he's learned
through ABA which was number one
brushing his teeth number two washing
his face number three learning to stop
when Mommy says stop number
four is playing basketball with his
friends and number five is learning to
go
hearing
okay
yeah
e
try to move right along here how long
can how long do I have you for okay
another 15 okay all right so let's see
if we can do this in 15 minutes all
right open up the public hearing on uh
Rel of prior authorization for health
care and here from the
prime sponsor Senator how are you
and we apologize for the delay oh no
worries good afternoon Mr chair and
members of the committee my name is
Denise rardy and I have the honor of
representing New Hampshire Senate
District 9 which includes the wonderful
communities of Bedford Fitz William
Greenfield Hinsdale Jaffrey lineboro
Mont Vernon New Boston Richmond Sharon
Temple Troy and
Winchester I am pleased to testify as
the prime sponsor of Senate Bill
561 relative to prior authorization for
healthc care over the past several
months I've been working with sponsors
of this bill and healthc Care leaders
from across the state including
representatives from the New Hampshire
Hospital Association the New Hampshire
Medical
Society America's health insurance plans
and the New Hampshire Department of
Insurance to draft legislation in
response to the concerns that I've heard
from my constituents about their
challenges with prior
authorization while prior authorization
can help ensure Medical Care is
necessary and appropriate it can also be
an obstacle to necessary patient care
when providers must navigate complex and
widely varying payer requirements or
face very long Waits for prior
authorization decisions this bill will
remove barriers to Patient Care by
streamlining prior authorization
requirements on insurers websites the
bill codifies into New Hampshire statue
a clear peer-to-peer process for
providers to engage with a clinical peer
from their patients insurance carrier
for a direct exchange on the basis of
the prior authorization request this
bill also requires carriers regulated by
the New Hampshire Department of
Insurance to report on prior
authorization metrics in line with a new
federal rule from the centers for
Medicare and Medicaid
services as I noted this bill is in
direct response to concerns from my
constituents too many Granite Staters
are left in limbo waiting for approval
from their insurance company to move
forward with important Medical Care this
bill enacts a reasonable timeline for
carriers to make a prior authorization
determination in line with Federal
timeline regulations this will allow the
New Hampshire Department of Insurance to
enforce timely prior authorization
decisionmaking on the health insurance
plans that it regulates this bill breaks
down the barriers to make it much easier
for doctors and nurses to provide care
that people really need to stay healthy
finally although we have not had a
specific study on the expected savings
from this bill by enacting efficiencies
and streamlined prior authorization
process Senate Bill 561 should put
downward pressure on insurance premiums
and the cost to provide care in fact a
recent rule from CMS that includes many
of the same Provisions as in Senate Bill
561 estimates the rule will result in in
at least 16 billion in savings over 10
years and a reduction in provider burden
of at least 220 million hours over 10
years
nationally in closing I would like to
thank all the stakeholders who worked
with me and the other sponsors of this
bill to bring forward a great compromise
amendment that is supported by both
providers carriers the insurance
department and in working with these
stakeholders it is clear to me that all
parties advocate in the best interests
of their patients their members and all
of our constituents I want to thank you
for the opportunity to introduce Senate
Bill 561 and if you have any questions
answer uh we do have a
question yesst Mr chair yes thank you um
Senator I have a question about whether
this goes beyond a doctor or a nurse
does it apply to people with physical
therapy or any other um uh person that
administers uh Healthcare yes the it it
will do that it will not um address
issue any other question representative
Bros thanks for taking my
question excuse me as a wife of a former
emergency Doctor Who had to deal with
this a lot um so I see the 72h hour uh
has to be 72 hours in an urgent
situation what happens if they don't get
that that authorization within the 72
hours what happens um automatic approval
oh
okay you have to be you have to have a
response from the insurance carrier
within seven days even if it's non-
urgent if you don't have a response from
the insurance carrier it would be
automatic approval now a response does
not mean that you know they may need
more information and but you do have to
hear from the carrier within seven days
full that's the biggest part of the bill
that was really important to me I had
too many people where their health care
was declining while they were waiting
the other really important part of this
bill to me that I love is that it's
peer-to-peer review so there won't be an
instance now where maybe your
cardiologist is talking to a podiatrist
it will be peer-to-peer this is really
good for the State of New Hampshire and
again the fact that the insurance
department all the stakeholders the
insurance carriers we worked we had at
least six very long meetings over months
till we came to something we could all
walk in and when we walked into um
Senate Health and Human Services we
right for the question I would follow up
and and again it may be in the bill it's
just my memory just is not very good in
terms of retaining all the information
in here let's say you have an emergency
and you really need an answer for
something within an hour em emergency is
if you deem it as emergency it goes
through there's no issue okay emergency
is an emergency okay it's more if I'll
give you an example if I may your doctor
thinks maybe you need an MRI of your
brain y doesn't think it's urgent but
really you need it this will allow or
enable the insurance carries to respond
within s days instead of you know months
long down the road but an emergency is
no issue okay thank
you represent Ammon thank you Mr chair
thank you senator for taking our
questions um I have a question about the
peer-to-peer review process if you could
just uh elaborate on how that would work
well when the doctor goes to put in the
request for the prior
authorization that request can include a
peer-to-peer review so that the person
on the other end of the um in the other
end of deciding on the prior
authorization has the knowledge about
question it means the person they're
talking to is knows what they're talking
about is the is the thank position for
that that patient well there in the same
field okay if that's help helps in the
old days some of the complaints uh I
remember way back when we did 7-Eleven
was that that uh some it wasn't even a
medical director it was sometimes it was
a nurse who was getting who worked for
the insurance to company and or just an
employee who then just looks up and and
and takes the information and deci made
that determination so what they're
saying is you want someone who actually
is in the field knows what they're
talking about
it's in the best interest of the patient
which is what we what this bill will
actually
do there fair enough thank you very much
thank you for your
time okay uh chair will call up the
and thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is still DJ beton
court and I still have the pleasure of
serving as the commissioner of the New
Hampshire insurance department want to
just emphasize two things that Senator
rardy mentioned first is this was a
wonderful example of stakeholders coming
together and working productively and
collaboratively to reach an end product
that all sides are an agreement is a
good product and so I do want to thank
as the senator did everybody who came
together to bring this important reform
that is before you today it is important
to remember remember that prior
authorization while a paino for a lot of
providers and patients is a key
component of our managed care system and
it is aimed to in the first instance
control cost but more importantly it is
aimed at ensuring that the patient is
getting the most appropriate care in the
most appropriate setting and so I know
that there has been some movement uh
some uh growing attitudes towards trying
to vastly erode or outright eliminate
prior authorization I don't think that's
the way that we want to go what I do
acknowledge however is that this is a
bureaucratic and at times cumbersome
system and when you have those types of
systems you have to constantly be
challenging yourself to make the system
better to reform it to streamline it to
make it more efficient and I think that
those concepts are captured in this
proposal so as I mentioned the insurance
department worked Clos closely with
stakeholders including Senator rardy
representative Nagel representatives
from the insurance industry the hospital
Association and the medical society to
come up with consensus language included
in the bill as amended before you the
parties all came to the table in good
faith and with open minds which allow
the group to reach agreement on
important improvements to the prior
authorization process these improvements
help make the prior authorization
process more efficient and will ensure
that patients receive time family
responses to prior authorization
requests in particular it requires
carriers to process prior authorization
requests within seven calendar days when
submitted electronically and 14 calendar
days when submitted using non-electronic
processes in urgent situations a
decision must be made within 72 hours
the request will be deemed appropriate
if the carrier fails not to to fails to
make a decision in the allotted time the
proposed Bill also set standards for
reviewers making the determination to
ensure that the reviewer has appropriate
credentials and expertise necessary to
apply the clinical
criteria the proposed Bill allows
providers the option to get more
flexibility to provide uh peer-to-peer
review prior to receiving a denial this
can help streamline the process by
allowing providers access to
peer-to-peer especially with complicated
situations that may require more of an
explanation and finally the bill will
require my department the insurance
department to post certain prior
authorization metrics for each carrier
on its website to improve transparency
and to empower consumers with critical
information I would note that as the
senator did uh several of these reforms
are as a result of the federal
government finalizing a proposed rule
around reforming prior
authorization those components are
captured in the amendment the benefit
before you is that in many instances
what is going to be federally required
is now
fast-tracked uh to take effect sooner
the carriers understand that they're
going to have to go through this process
anyway and as part of their end of the
compromise they've agreed to as I said
expedite what is going to be required of
them and that is captured in The
Proposal before you so with that said
we're happy to take
questions uh I don't know if this is for
you or Al who who did the fiscal
note the department did I would assum
because the senator said this was going
to save us $16 billion do and and I
don't see that in the fiscal Noe at all
I see this could be incrementally costs
us
money right I realize but let's just
say because the fiscal node says there's
potential incremental cost because this
peer-to-peer might mean they're going to
have to pay for somebody more expensive
to take the phone call and
then and and then yeah so yeah our
fiscal note was more
shortterm uh
Vision short okay all right all right so
but so theoretically didn't know
necessarily any actual savings and we
don't know that there really is that's
more speculative yes okay that makes me
feel better thank
you any other questions for the det
Department yes I I want to would you
believe that I'm uh I really like it
when the state is making an effort to
synthesize with the feder government and
and that's all I have to say thank you
thank you very much would you believe I
would most of the time thank you very
much Gent thank you welcome uh I
apologize representative Nagel I didn't
areel yeah you're supposed to you
co-sponsor of the bill yeah I'm supposed
to call you up sooner rather than later
you're going to save the Dust for last
yeah I could could have done that but we
always assume that you have other
important business to attend to I
actually
go um there's two handouts there that um
the one I'd already sent all of you um
it's just my written testimony the other
one is a statement from the AMA about
why this issue is important and I didn't
really want to spend a lot of time to go
over these details with you for the
record I'm David Nagel I'm a
representative I'm also a physician I
practiced in New Hampshire for 34 years
now um I've been involved in advocacy
work um for a very long period of time
standing up for the rights of patients
um I wrote a book a couple years ago on
Pain Care policy and um there is a
chapter actually or section in a chapter
on prior authorization and its potential
good and bad effects on how we care for
people this is a very important issue
for me that's why I spent a lot of time
on it I extremely honored to have been
part of this multi- um
stakeholder group um I'm so honored to
work with do uh doctor you are now a
doctor rardy Senator rardy on this um on
this bill and it's it's been a real
great learning experience for me um one
of the things that's really important to
me and why this bill is important is
that we're in a in a healthc care
climate right now where we're watching
The Rise the fall of the Private
Practice where at some point in time it
will cease to exist and that really
scares me and there are two cost reasons
that are killing Private Practice one is
the electronic record and the other is
prior authorization the question was
asked earlier about you know non doctor
practices physical therapists
chiropractors things like that um as
they become part of the medical
mainstream I keep asking them all over
and over why do you want to be part of
the medical mainstream you can't afford
it and and I don't think that's a good
thing and that's why reforms of this
type are important
um my role in this and why how this came
to be that's what I want to focus on I I
am a middle child born on a Wednesday I
end up in the middle of everything um my
colleagues will be very upset with me to
hear me say that I think prior
authorization is important the reason
it's important is doctors are really
good at assessing risk benefit and
meaningful outcome of our interventions
we stink when it comes to cost benefit
and there needs to be some level of
oversight and as was stated earlier
that's what the point of prior
authorization is however the system
doesn't work very well I I think um my
folks my colleagues at the insurance
commission were polite in saying how the
system can work I think it has a lot of
problems in reform is important on the
sheets I handed out you I listed all the
problems my uh transcript of uh my note
I listed all the problems I don't really
want to go in any detail the way we
started looking at this was well over a
year
ago um I talked to the folks at the
medical society when I ran for office I
said this was important to me what do we
do they showed me the legislation that
had been looked over at the last couple
years and it really didn't address
meaningful broad-based reform and I said
well we really got to do something
better so why don't we hear from you
know the people find out well what are
the problems so Mike padmore who used to
be with the med Society put together a
town hall meeting for us and and we sat
down uh there were 50 doctors a lot from
private practice I was impressed by that
and we sat down and looked at what are
the problems everything was listed on
what I just handed you um and what are
the potential Solutions what do we need
to accomplish I mean issues of
transparency cost time energy all those
things were listed so then we looked and
found that the AMA had already done all
the work for us they created a template
on a meaningful healthc care reform this
is a huge issue for them there are 90
bills in 30 States looking at this issue
and that's why it's really important um
and I looked at it and I said well this
is a good template for where to start so
that's what we did I then went beyond
that because again I'm concerned about
other people so I met with a physical
therapist I met with the chiropractors I
said whatat do you guys want out of this
and we started looking at well you know
what could we do and so whatever we did
whatever reform measure we did it had to
satisfy everybody not just Physicians
that was really important to me and I'm
very honored that that's been honored in
this process
um once all that was done we sat down
and created a subcommittee and we wanted
to look through the am guide and see
well how does this work for New
Hampshire and that's what we did um we
looked at their model as a template
Michigan had already passed the law we
looked at that as a model we looked at
several of the other state models in the
midst of all this Paul am minahan had
pointed out that Senator rardy was very
interested and she did one of the
smartest things ever um we sat down
talked with her and it was her
suggestion that we sit down and talk
with the insurers about that and that's
what led to this you know
multi-stakeholder effort um and that's
what led to the bill that's right before
you um God shined Upon Us 3 days before
our Senate testimony this Ms reforms
were released it's 800 Pages if you've
got nothing better to do to look through
that I do have a shortened version of
that but what we found was what they did
what we did was very similar and that
made us feel better and the reason why
that was important was a lot of people
weren't thrilled with what we were doing
because it would only affect the
commercial insurance industry which is
like 25% of the market the minute we did
this with them 75% of the market
overnight and that was a that was a
really important thing because for this
to be meaningful it had to be more
broad-based um and as was stated their
estimate is that we're going to save $15
billion nationally you asked about the
financial note I have a lot of concerns
about that so um you know as far as I I
personally see that in the long term
especially I'm going to take a step back
and say that this is a start it's not a
finish there's other things that we want
to accomplish things that aren't in
there that really involve a lot more
discussion um you know things like how
do we pick what evidence base we use
because right now every insurance
company has their own that's crazy why
can't we have a uniform evidence base so
we don't have to all know what each
insurer wants that's a step forward
there's this concept of gold cards that
you may or may not have heard of where
if I'm really good with my prior
authorizations I it's like that easy
pass thing at the you know when you're
going through the metal detectors at the
airport I can't remember what it's
called it it'd be like that you just go
right through and all of a sudden you're
not costing the system money you're
saving money for everybody and and and
so I think in the end I mean I think
everybody benefits the financial note
points out a cost to the insurer but to
the private practitioners we seem to get
and in and not insurers the private
practitioners and the regular docs I'm
not sure why we get lost in this because
we would save a lot of money a lot of
time a lot of energy and maybe I can
grow my hair back um and I think that
that's pretty much all I've had the last
thing I wanted to say again it's been an
honor to work with everybody um I don't
think of this as a finish but a start
and we created relationships that I
think are lasting that are going to go
on for a while um because this is this
is just a beginning so thank you thank
you any questions from the committee
members seeing none thanks I have a good
one I think more than three minutes uh
before I get to all the people who are
in support we'll hear from Heidi who
says she supports but also neutral you
must be neutral about
okay um Mr chairman and members of the
committee for the record my name is
Heidi croll I work at Gallagher Callahan
and gartell um representing ahip
America's health insurance plans the
neutral part was simply that you know we
weren't um we weren't we didn't initiate
the bill but we were very happy as other
speakers have indicated um to um work
collaboratively with the Senators and um
representative Nagel and the
stakeholders um the insurance department
um so you know I want to sincerely thank
everybody it was as they've described um
a great stakeholder effort um everyone
worked really hard and we collaborated
um in order to get to this amendment um
um as you've heard lotss of meetings um
lots of time and effort um so as you've
heard from me uh and the carrier say on
many occasions uh utilization management
including prior authorization does play
a very important role in Managed Care um
prior authorization ensures that patient
care is consistent with most up-to-date
evidence-based practices um it helps
lower a patients um out of pocket cost
so they're not paying for Unnecessary
care or they're not paying for more
expensive care when there might be lower
cost Alternatives available that are
appropriate to try first um it prevents
the overuse and misuse of care as well
as potentially um avoids harmful care um
and finally it does trigger additional
care coordination um for um you know in
terms of the services for the patient so
um From ahip's perspective this
amendment does a good job to ensure that
these benefits of prior authorization
will continue um while also addressing
the interest of the sponsors and the
providers um as you heard in mid January
of this year CMS finalized its latest
rules on prior authorization to
streamline the process um and the timing
was very helpful in that the
stakeholders were able to kind of sync
up some of the key provisions of the New
Hampshire proposal um with the federal
proposal so I think it will be very
helpful to Providers and the carriers
alike um in standard standardizing some
common practices um for example we have
aligned the turnaround times for you for
issuing prior authorization decisions
with the federal rules um we have
aligned with moving toward um greater
use of electronic prior authorization
which the CMS rules um ultimately
require of the carriers and the
providers to kind of improve efficiency
and streamline the process so um with
that I'd be happy to try to answer any
questions and um appreciate your time
Andes has a
question thank you for for letting me
ask the question do you feel that
there's any confusion at the beginning
of the process to understand exactly
what requires prior authorization either
on the provider side or the you know
insured side I I always found that very
confusing of what what I what needs
prior authorization and then if you
don't get prior off you get the service
you get the bill you thought it was
covered and it gets
confusing yeah I think by and large
um I think providers are familiar with
what you know in their day-to-day
practice what requires prior
authorization I think they're pretty
familiar with that um and of course if
they're using electronic systems they'll
Al you know get alerted electronically
about whether something requires a prior
authorization so um it's not to say that
it's a perfect system but I think by and
large people do understand um where
those requirements are and carriers have
you know they're continually viewing um
what um Services uh and products uh
medical products do require prior
authorization so they're continually um
you know things that may have required
prior authorization um no longer due um
and then other things that may be new in
the pipeline um might require it but I
you know I do think there's I think
there's communication going on there
that the doctors are
aware thank you very much thank thank
Association hello Mr chairman members of
the committee for the record my name is
Ben Bradley I'm the vice president of
state government relations for the New
Hampshire Hospital Association I am not
going to read my testimony but I do want
to cover a couple
things you heard about the uh
stakeholders coming together and coming
to an agreement working together on a
solution abide at the Apple on prior
authorization uh you heard about the
importance of prior authorization what
value it brings but yet the burdens uh
that come with that and how this bill
attempts to address
those um in line with uh how CMS put
forward their rule on prior
authorization um you heard about the uh
National savings projections and
although something hasn't been done
similarly in New Hampshire I think we
can reflect on those National Savings of
billions of dollars projected in savings
from uh the rule from
CMS um I wanted to quickly address a
question that uh you had representative
P pelli Portell um related to um what's
expected of a in prior authorization and
knowing and not knowing and what what
should be submitted I think Heidi
covered that well but I'd also say
elements of this bill pull from the CM
Ms rule for requirements to publish um
what's expected for prior authorization
so the hope is that transparency will um
help inform providers as well um I too
want to extend my appreciation for
everyone who came together on this
important bill and ask for your support
questions thank you very
much chair yeah can we have your written
of
course uh chair Callin Holly Stevens
bill chairman hunt members of the
committee my name is Holly Stevens I'm
the director of public policy at Nami
New Hampshire
Nami is a nonprofit Grassroots
organization whose mission is to improve
the lives of all people impacted by
mental illness and suicide through
support education and advocacy on behalf
of Nami New Hampshire I'm here today to
speak in support of Senate Bill 561 um
as you've heard F Senate Bill 561
establishes criteria around Prior
authorizations and given the current
variability variability of the way prior
authorizations are used this is a
welcome change in mental health care
prior authorizations are Mo most often
used with medications higher levels of
care such as residential or intensive um
outpatient programs um as well as newer
treatment procedures such as
transcranial magnetic stimulation and
ketamine assisted
therapy the application of Prior
authorizations by insurers can have a
detrimental effect on the health and
well-being of their members and can
disproportionately fect those seeking
Mental Health Care according to a recent
Kaiser Family Foundation survey which
I've included for you folks um 26% of
people who sought treatment for a mental
health condition in the past year
experienced an issue with prior
authorization as compared to 133% of
folks who did not um seek mental health
care so folks that are seeking Mental
Health Care um are twice as likely to
experience an issue um around a prior
authorization with their with their
health carrier um additionally people
who whose insurance issues included
prior authorizations were three times
more likely to report being unable to
receive medical care or treatment that
was recommended by their provider as a
direct result of their issues with their
with the uh prior
authorization um and we also know that
um the survey showed that uh a majority
of folks who had issues with prior
authorizations also had
detrimental uh effects to their health
and had increased out-of-pocket costs
due to prior authorization issues so we
do know that this is an issue and
although we were not a part of the group
that came together we are um thankful
that everybody came together on to work
on this legislation um and we do ask for
great thank you thank you chair we'll
call On Em Emma
Futures thank you chairperson hunt and
honorable members of the committee my
name is Emma savini I am the children's
Behavioral Health policy coordinator for
new Futures new Futures is a nonpartisan
nonprofit organization that solves
problems through policy change in this
role we work extensively with policy
makers uh Healthcare Providers and
families to Pro to increase access to
quality affordable health care um we are
here in strong support of Senate Bill
561 um for all of the reasons you've
heard already um and we just wanted to
highlight a few um we uh appreciate that
this bill would go far to provide both
patients and providers with the
information they need to more promptly
come up with a a um plan of care based
on the insurance coverage available to a
a patient secondly um we really
appreciate that this would help ensure
insurance carriers are utilizing medical
research and best practices to make
decisions that are in the patients best
interest through that peer-to-peer
resource that was mentioned and we also
really appreciate that this would
provide patients providers and state
Regulators with the information they
would they need to hold Insurance
insurers to account and ensure that they
are working to support access to patient
care um for those reasons new Futures
would urge this committee uh to vote
Senate Bill 561 ought to pass and I'm
questions perfect thank you
better okay dear members of the House
committee thank you for taking the time
to hear my testimony today uh my name is
Jennifer Christensen I have been a
practicing physician for 20 years here
in New Hampshire uh the majority of my
patients have opioid use disorder and uh
I currently am a solo practitioner I've
been part of this uh from the beginning
I was there when Mike padmore had the uh
commit the meeting right back to my
notes um and uh I I my outpatient clinic
motivated Health choices in naswa I also
work at marac for a for-profit clinic so
that I can keep my office uh running in
nashwa I'm strongly in favor of the
Senate Bill 561 my patients uh who do
well they become active members of the
workforce and they increase their work
and they end up going to a commercials
insurance and usually lose their uh
ability to get medication at that point
um if they're not allowed to continue
their medication assisted recovery they
go into withdrawals and even with
withdrawal medications there is a chance
of relapse uh I I keep my patients out
of the ER because they come to me for
medications and um they do very well uh
I can tell you about all the deaths that
I've had while awaiting for uh prior
offs but I think that can that can be
left as a non-spoken thing if they have
any
questions none thank you thank you so
hi I'm Steve Gardner thank you for uh
hearing me uh I didn't prepare a written
uh uh statement here uh this is
something I learned of just a few weeks
ago that there was a public hearing and
uh and just learned today that I could
speak um but we we had personally a case
I've had two cases now where prior
authorization has impacted Health uh uh
last year
my my wife went to the
doctor um and they did an x-ray
abdominal X-ray and determined that uh
they weren't able to determine what the
issue was she hadn't been feeling well
for a few
weeks um and they uh asked to get a CAT
scan they said we'll have to get prior
authorization so we waited for that uh a
few days later we ended up in the
emergency room at
conquered uh and she had a perforated
diabetica infected her uh whole abdomen
spent three weeks in the hospital in
critical care and has since gone through
multiple surgeries uh thankfully she's
with us
today um but the prior
authorization prevented us from going
ahead and getting the CAT scan done uh
immediately and they do say at the at
the doctor's office if you feel it's an
emergency go to the emergency room and
we didn't think it was uh necessary to
go there so we
waited uh and that was a mistake
obviously uh but the prior authorization
process the way it is now I I got the
denial two weeks later I opened it up on
Christmas Eve seeing I got a denial and
just about went through the roof uh I've
since been doing doing a lot of research
on prior authorization and how this has
impacted people the AMA as as one of the
people of reference has done a lot of
Articles uh on prior authorization the
need for reform this bill goes a long
ways to promote that but uh not far
enough uh the
electronic um having this data
electronically available should be able
to get the doctor's authorization on the
spot they shouldn't have to wait even 72
hours for Urgent request because many of
the criteria are you know I went through
and looked at the criteria for um my
wife's case and they required a
abdominal x-ray which she had and for
some reason it was deemed medically
unnecessary um I had another case a few
we a few years earlier where I had a a
kidney stone prior authorization similar
issue it was uh denied they they say go
to the emergency room well I wasn't
going to go to the emergency room it was
during Co at that time uh so I wasn't
stepping uh into an emergency
room wasn't an emergency so I so I
didn't go just went through the pain
ended up having it removed uh and they
did CAT scans in order to remove it
because it was something that wasn't
going to pass um but the prior
authorization process currently uh
definitely needs to be reformed and I'm
glad to hear that there's going to be
additional bills coming through I don't
know if you remember representative
buroughs I contacted you uh a little
over a year ago concerning prior
authorization uh and trying to get a
bill uh started and I'm glad to see that
this uh is is now in place and I hope
that everyone here supports it thank
you questions represent
buros just a quick question in case of
your wife um if she had gotten the prior
authorization quickly would it have
prevented some of the consequent
surgeries Etc uh I certainly can't say
for certain because it was a few days
later that we were in the emergency room
um but she needed that surgery
immediately and what happened is it it
ruptured and infected her whole
abdomen uh and every every day every
hour counts when you're you have an
infection that
bad um so I don't think the perforation
had uh
fully uh infected her abdomen at that
point and few day a few days later we
in thank you for coming appreciate it
okay I
have
uh uh no more cards and oh so 30 we have
32 people in sport one person opposed
that's the online yeah the online okay
with that I'm going to close the
hearing and get ready for this next one
here
cards do we close just for my own scar
do we close at five no matter uh I was
thinking
it
e
so Senator Apprentice do I have a card
yes okay you handed it to me that would
that would be
dangerous okay I Ed it over there okay
well why don't we go ahead I got a card
go okay uh just general announcements
because I see we have a lot of people
who want to share and um that they want
us out of here at
5:00 okay so all I can do is be ask you
to be a model of brevity um I lot of you
have very uh uh familiar faces because
this is not the first ambulance bill we
have had in this committee nor the first
so you're on I'm on great thank thank
you good afternoon share hunt members of
house Commerce and consumer affairs this
is uh time number two that I'm joining
you today and just for the record it's
my daughter Phoebe's 27th birthday so
Phoebe if you're out there your mother's
wishing you a happy birthday um and also
for the record my name is Su Prentice
I'm the state senator from District 5
covering a large part of Grafton part of
Sullivan County and one town in marac
County the beautiful town of New London
so I am here today to introduce Senate
bill
407 um this bill would require in an
emergency and when out of network
commercial insurers to pay ambulance
services directly for the care and
transportation provided at rates set by
a community in a public process or a
percentage of Medicare whichever is less
and I'm going to go into detail but not
too much because I've got five o'clock
on my mind so during emergencies
patients the consumers of healthcare
should not have have to worry about
being in or being out of network nor
should the ambulance services when
trying to navigate these situations so
it's Groundhog Day for you it's a little
Groundhog Day for me as well um I
visited a house study committee report
that was issued in 2018 and I actually
think one of the hearings I was here for
you representative am and you you were
able to you had located this as well and
in this report it cites going back to
2009 the problem of insurance carrier
reimburse ment for ambulance service
Services has been discussed in the New
Hampshire legislature one of the final
recommendations in this document is the
direct pay part of this bill however
here we are again now I understand
you've passed 1081 um thank you very
much I think it's a great bill and I
really appreciate all your hard work on
that but as it stands today if you call
for help and you are transported and you
have commercial insurance coverage the
payment for that service often goes to
the patient not to the provider of the
service I mean we have this established
in this committee you know exactly what
I'm talking about so I won't belabor
this but I just want to be clear that at
the time you dial 911 or you need an
emergency transfer to a higher level of
care so that's like if you're a trauma
patient we needs to go to Dartmouth or
go to Boston this should not be an issue
worrying about whether you're a network
or not the closest most appropriate
appropriate service should be the key
consideration um but and uh I've asked
the um I've spoken with ahip um and
tried to get a copy or a list a full
list of all the ambulance services that
are in network just so that that can be
considered as part of the conversation
and Heidi croll has been helpful but we
don't have a full list yet um and I
trust I and have assurance that we'll
get that because that's something that
even through a couple months of
discussion I'm not completely clear I
know more are out of network that are in
network but I'd like to be able to it's
what you think what you know and what
you can prove I'd like to be able to
that out for you so the unwillingness or
inability to pay services directly
regardless of network status has
resulted in putting patients in the
middle because they're getting they're
getting the check and some of them don't
know what to do with it and some of them
do um and it creates a gap in Revenue
that's left the taxpayer to cover so the
Valley News which is I'm from Lebanon is
my hometown newspaper actually wrote an
article on this on July 26 2024 Rising
ambulance fees highlight shortfalls from
health insurance payments and it talks
about this cost shifting that's
happening because of this Gap that's
been created so let's talk about the
cost of
service I believe and especially after
you know serving at the local level I am
a paramedic I've been a paramedic maybe
many too many years I get my hair
colored so I'm thinking we're going
somewhere on 30 to 32 years of being a
paramedic but I also have served as a
city councelor um and a mayor and so I
understand how communities make the
decisions that they do about the
services that they want to provide and
what it's going to cost them so based on
their size their location and the volume
of emergency calls a community will
decide how they're going to provide
emergency medical coverage this could be
one ambulance two ambulances are you
going to have a certain level of provide
of level of care that's available these
are decisions that communities make and
I don't want to get in the middle of
communities making those decisions just
like any other health healthare service
ambulance care and transportation is a
covered service by the public payers
which is Medicare and Medicaid and
private so they would be our signat our
signat signas long day Anthem and I saw
um Peter bragon here from Harvard
Pilgrim Healthcare um these but it has
to be part of the plan so the plan
includes if it includes ambulance
Transportation then these private payers
have a role in covering an ambulance
bill that one of their benefici gets
most if not all communities use a
convention what I call it's conventional
wisdom a mix of a per capita assessment
for
Revenue to help support the emergency
medical operation um and then there's
also the revenue from the billing of the
patients um we also recognize that there
is a self pay component to this because
not everybody has Medicare Medicaid or
even private insurance Co coverage we're
really close but we recognize that there
are some self-pay cases that come that
come into play the per capita largely
covers the cost of Readiness um and the
revenue from the billing of the
insurance carriers whether it's public
or private covers largely the cost of
care and
transportation New England New Hampshire
part of New England traditionally has
lower reimbursement rates two GAO
reports so our governmental Accounting
Office says a Medicare reimbursing
ground ambulance service has been
reimbursing ground Ambulance Service
below cost that's according to Fair pay
in the past year for the first time in
17 years we did see a raise from
Medicaid they went from 38% to 50% to
100% of Medicare and that's great but
over time um this lower than average
reimbursement this issue with public and
private and combined payments going to
patients has shifted costs and
destabilized the system so yes we have
gotten a raise for Medicaid but we've
been functioning for 17 years at the
lowest average in New England now we're
not that's something we should all be
proud of but still we have this problem
the mems system in New Hampshire is not
unlike the rest of our nation which is
struggling reimbursement is a key
contributing factor to the impending
failure of our Primary Care safety net
Emergency Medical
Services in order to do the work we need
sustainable wages for our Personnel Safe
Transportation we do need
state-of-the-art equipment because
that's what you would want if you were
sick or a family member of yours was
sick and just like hospitals to be both
you they they have state-of-the-art
equipment this to be built specifically
for use in the field without aligning
reimbursement and including paying
amulance Services directly for work done
and at a rate that covers their costs we
are enabling mounting pressure and again
a lack of stability in a system you
can't turn around well I mean I'm in the
business so I'm watching this every day
but there are consistently articles on a
daily basis about the shortages of of
Workforce about the shortages of
ambulances some states are actually like
like leaning into subsidies that's not
what we're asking for here we're trying
to approach this from a number of
different ways to see if we can bring
some stabilization to the problem so
that's why we need your help so Senate
Bill 407 specifically well back to my
very my opening this is for out of
Network rates and these rates are set by
the community on the reasons that I told
you how they decide how they're going to
deliver their service what it costs them
so it's the rate set by the community or
3 25% of Medicare whichever is lower
this bill does not set rates it does not
raise rates it sets a floor that
communities can count on to cover their
costs for when it's an emergency or it
is what we call again an unscheduled
transfer to a higher level of care why
325 per this is a question that I've
heard from a number of people well first
of all five states have adopted 325
per they either the the rate that's been
set by the community or 325 per of
Medicare some Indiana adopted actually
higher they're at
400% some of the folks from the fire
service and Emergency Medical Services
Community will provide specific examples
of how this would impact them but just a
quick story I was speaking with the loud
and fire chief we used to work together
up in a place called Woodsville New
Hampshire and he's now the chief down
here he called me up and he said sue
it's kind of like the Three Bears we
don't you know we don't want we don't
need too much we can't continue to get
too little can you bring us somewhere in
the middle so we can do our
job so that's that's one part of it
again New Hampshire communities set
their rate in a public setting by
ordinance or by contract local officials
raise their hand to approve or not what
rates their Ambulance Service will
charge in a publicly held open process
not behind closed
doors this bill only applies again to
emergencies and again the unscheduled
transfers this bill aligns it with the
dispute process that's currently um
managed by the department of insurance
and if the work um s SP 173 goes forward
which is surprise medical billing which
you talked about earlier today I believe
then we would fall under that for
dispute process but right now it points
to the existing one and would carry over
um I um I'll wrap up by saying that I do
really I know it you know it's like
Groundhog Day and we've been talking
about this for a while but it's really
come to a ahead and we're trying to
build stability into this system I've
heard concerns that have been raised and
I just want to address them here that
this would promote cost shifting that
communities would say let's raise our
ambulance rat so we can get other things
that's not how we do our business that's
not the point of this there we're just
saying communities make these decisions
this is what it costs them so if it's an
emergency why can't we take care of that
or a percentage of that help to
stabilize the system and pay the
providers directly so I'm happy to take
any questions I'll do my best I have
other people here who um have much who
have specific examples how this has
impacted their community and our
technical experts in the reimbursement
World which I cannot profess to be thank
you very much for your
time questions we'll start with
representative
burrow thanks senator for taking my
question for the five states that you
said are are using this model um have
they found it to be a sustainable
business model it has so thank you for
the question representative burrow this
has all happened within the last two
years so I don't have the data to
provide other than anecdotal so Indiana
Indiana is the latest State and New York
State just passed
direct pay at full cost with no
percentage of Medicare it was signed
into law by the governor this past fall
so I imagine that not imagine I know
that if we were to have this
conversation maybe two to three years
from now we'd have some data to look at
whether this is working thank you repres
Ammon thank you Mr chair and thank you
senator for taking our questions um I
just have a question about uh the
possibility or maybe you could explain
to me is is it possible that this could
disincentivize uh ambulance providers
from Contracting with insurers and uh
establishing a in network relationship
is there a way that this could
disincentivize that I'm just trying to
see the downside oh thank you
representative M for the question and I
welcome it in fact I actually think
it'll incentivize look there incentivize
ambulance services to go in network
there's almost been like a standoff if I
may kind of an okay Corral over this for
a number of years so if we could all
show good faith on both sides I think
people should get into network but I'm
not privy to those negotiations or what
is offered to these Services during this
but what I know is I have a willing and
able EMS community that wants wants to
move in that direction but this
standof has to end and we have to come
together so my position on this it's a
great question is it actually I believe
will incentivize because we'll find the
good faith and we can start working
together thank
you representative Sullivan
thank you um so this is going to
highlight my ignorance on all of this
sort of stuff but can you explain why
Medicare is like the standard so I mean
is is Medicare just allowed because it's
the government to underpay everything is
that how it works and then like the
private insurance has to subsidize
things by paying multiple times what
that is or whatever the cost is so for
number thank you for the question
representative Sullivan so for a number
of years Medicare was the standard you
know it was the place when I ran an
ambulance service in the North country
you know that was our most reliable form
of reimbursement outside of again the
per capita assessment per head but just
like other things it has been left to
wither has not been appropriately um
well it's being appropriately assessed
now but it's been left to wither and has
it has fallen off and is now running
lower than average rather than being the
gold standard than it once was of these
providers behind me have completed a
survey that was sent to them by CMS that
actually does an assessment you know of
their service of their rates is getting
so they they are looking at from a CMS
perspective at rate you know basically
aligning Medicare with where it should
be because it's not there now so some of
the folks that have answered that survey
can probably respond better so no it's
not where it should be it's not the gold
standard anymore we're actually starting
to do better um you know on at least on
the Medicaid side we've seen that we've
like moved in the right direction we
need the feds to catch up with us yeah
thank you thank
you any other questions see none thank
you very much again I really appreciate
your time thank you okay uh so next up
I'm going to call is Alex F from the
insurance department and he is
opposition to the bill as
written with a nice little
star Alex said file folders
Senator yes uh thank you Mr chairman um
we're in opposition to Bill as written
but we've um worked very hard on this
issue um and we actually um just last
week have completed our work drafting an
amendment that I think would achieve uh
the goals of everyone in this room and
um we're happy to to share that today
I've already given a copy to Senator
Apprentice um but let me just start with
what the insurance uh Department a a
copy of unpublished version of the
amendment so we just drafted up
language
um uh the insurance department uh got uh
heavily involved in working on a
resolution this issue last summer when
we um hosted a series series of meetings
with the various parties who um are
interested in this issue of commercial
health insurance reimbursement uh for
ground ambulance services and about the
problem of balance billing um that many
consumers in the state have
experienced um uh we had a lot of
meetings um and a lot of interesting
discussions um and I made new friends um
um uh we issued we were ultimately
unable to come to agreement on a concept
I I feel that we came close um but uh we
tried to capture um what progress was
made um on the discussion with our
report that uh we issued that's on our
website and I also have a few copies
here if anyone's interested in that um
our perspective on uh this Center Bill
407 is as written is that it doesn't
really come out of the work of the um
the summit uh
meetings um and it's um narrowly
addressed to the simple issue of U
reimbursement for ambulance services
when what we really have is a cluster of
issues that includes the problem of
balance billing and uh the more Global
problem of sustaining a a vibrant ground
ambulance system in the state um because
we all know costs are going up and it is
a challenge for our local providers to
maintain the level of service that ought
to be there um so in terms of the summit
our goals were to deal with the problem
of balance
billing um to come up with a system for
adequate uh
reimbursement uh for am ground ambulance
services from commercial
insurance and uh to set up a process
that would address the longer term
systemic issues that um are confronting
ground ambulance providers in the state
just small example the treat um no
transport issue where uh ground
ambulance providers are having trouble
getting reimbursed but the have a lot of
expense for their
service
um what one of the um developments that
we found um encouraging was that the
health carriers step forward and showed
a willingness to increase their rates uh
for ground ambulance services if um in
effect they could buy an end to balance
billing with that increase um and and
one of the main concerns we have with
the bill as written is that it um does
not end balance billing so um it
establishes this rate of uh 325 per of
Medicare or actual charge which from our
claims data we found that actual charges
are roughly 325 per of Medicare so
they're in the you know in the ballpark
and that would
represent um roughly a doubling of
current allowed
um so the my point my main point is we
should if we're going to be dealing with
um the reimbursement issue um we should
also be um prohibiting balance billing
and this is what virtually every other
state has done who has set these rates
they also at the same time prohibit
balance billing um what I'd like to to
do is just to say what the goals are I
think um for the summit meetings and for
the amendment that that we're offering
uh for the committee's
consideration uh number one ground
ambulance services should be funded in a
manner that's sufficient to maintain an
adequate and sustainable ground
ambulance
system number two the burden of funding
a sustainable and adequate ground
ambulance system in the State Should
Fall not fall disproportionately on
commercially insured consumers everybody
should do their share and all consumers
in the state should be protected from
ground ambulance billing balance billing
and from the heightened risk of
untenable levels of consumer medical
debt for ground ambulance services
so just briefly um or as briefly as I
can what we're proposing in the um in in
our amendment is number one um a
Prohibition on balance billing and
number two the requirement of direct pay
uh to the
providers uh number three uh data
collection on ground ambulance
costs um one of the problems with
picking a ray to today is we do not have
good information about what cost and
what we heard over and over again from
the Fire Chiefs at the summit meetings
where they just want to be adequately
reimbursed for their costs including the
cost of
Readiness um and um in order to do that
we have to have uh collection of data on
cost so uh the amendment that we're
providing sets up a process where that
information could be collected
and then an Actuarial firm would take
that information and propose a rate
structure and the criteria for that rate
structure is that it must cover costs of
providing the care including the cost of
Readiness um in the interim um while the
cost information is being gathered our
uh proposed amendment uh would increase
the rates U because the prohibition on
Balan billing would go into effect right
away but not to the 325 per. we've
looked at our claims data and we see the
current allowed amounts right around
118% of Medicare for the most common
services so we uh our proposal would
raise the rates on this stepped scale
from 165 to 200% of Medicare as an
interim measure it would be temporary
and by the way these some of these other
states that are raising the rates are
also made them temporary uh because they
had the same idea that they're going to
take a temporary measure and then do
some work to get better information
about
costs um so the um what would need to
happen then is the actual rail firm
would uh propose a rate schedule there'd
be rule making to implement it with
public input and then there would need
to be um periodic review of that race
schedule for the effect on the market on
providers um and for any necessary
adjustments to the rate schedule and
then importantly uh the amendment that
we propos creates a commission going
forward to look at the more systemic
issues around um ground ambulance
services um that I mentioned or I I
mentioned some of them but uh they're
more to do with there more efficient
delivery methods that we can be using um
are there different policies we should
have for facility to facility transfers
versus Emergency
Services um and uh there a number of
important issues and this sets up a good
vehicle for addressing them going
forward um
so taking up more than my share of
time okay thank you Alex all right Nina
you're representative burs
okay repres my question is this has been
going on for a long time um why hasn't
uh the cost issue you know been
fulfilled I
mean are you saying that all these
people in the these you know the the
people that run the services have not
provided you information on costs in the
last 5 10 years is that what you're
looking for is uh I'm saying that yeah
we need
uh uniform information and the uh
medicare's effort to develop a uh cost
reporting template is very useful in
this regard because you need everybody
reporting in the same format what we did
during the summit was put out some
questions to the ambulance providers
relative to cost and we got answers in
different formats um with different
assumptions um and that has been
historically the the be barrier to
getting usable accurate data about cost
is we need to basically um have a
uniform method of accounting in order to
establish those costs and I think we we
have something that is great in that
tool okay representative
Bros thanks for taking my question um
the concern I mean the the things that
you described that you want to
accomplish all sound great but it sounds
like a really long time frame and we
have a situation here where we have
ambulance services in you know from what
we've heard past year in danger of going
under so you know how can
we move this forward so that we can help
these folks out now right that's why the
bill includes a short-term increase in
rates um remember we have the Medicaid
increase that just happened and then
under this proposed amendment there
would be an increase um in rates that's
substantial relative to the existing
existing allowed amounts and that would
cover the period that take of time that
it takes to do the study and develop a
permanent race schedule so yeah cost
would an increase would go into effect
right
away F the question yeah I think you
said would it it would go up from 100%
to 200 something is what you said yeah
and is that I guess you know we'll hear
from people is that going to be enough
in the interim to I see people shaking
their heads no is that going to be
enough to keep keep these places
afloat right um we've uh done a draft
fiscal note for our bill and for
47 um as um as written um the it's based
on the claims data so we just compare
existing payment amounts to the various
percentages of Medicare so the amendment
we've written would increase income to
ambulance providers by between two and
three million and the U Amendment uh the
bill as written would um increase
reimbursement to ambulance providers by
about 11 8.8 million or
$447 per member per
month
premium represent
spear okay so I'm looking forward to the
amendment when when will that Amendment
up not yeah just to remind everybody we
do have a subcommittee we'll be working
on this bill tomorrow morning at 9 o' so
we will certainly be addressing these
okay I'm sorry a follow on what did you
say the uh the cost per member per month
was going to be
$447 if we passed the bill as introduced
as yeah and so we can assume this is 2
million so this is a lot less that's
around a dollar a dollar so okay
represent Ammon thank you Mr chair thank
you for presenting your Amendment here
um I have a question the original
language of the bill it's a line 11 and
it talks about a public process um you
know in your understanding if could you
explain how the public process would
work in the original Bill and do you
address that in the
amendment um no in the amendment there's
no reference to the local rate setting
that's typically done at the municipal
level um the concept that um we're
putting forward in the amendment is that
there be an actuar derived Statewide
rate schedule that actually would vary
from region to region but that's how it
would be derived so my understanding is
that under the uh Municipal process
there's a public hearing for setting
rates and that's about as much as I know
about
that okay are we all said thank you very
much
thanks okay
uh so obviously a lot of you here want
to come and tell us how this is this
bills the greatest thing since sliced
bread um and solves everything but I
think it's important we uh get a
balanced point of view here so I'm going
to mix it up between for and against it
so uh we'll start out with Chris tas's
Bill thank you thank you Mr chairman
Chris stay was Halls New Hampshire um
New Hampshire Ambulance Association
sorry I just got to bring up my
testimony here and it would be a little
bit different now that we've got an
amendment
um which um I have to point I have
haven't seen the
amendment however um after 407
unanimously passed the Senate we saw an
offer from the insurers for the very
first time didn't get an offer didn't
get anything from them throughout the
whole ambulance Summit and it sounds
very much like the amendment which um we
had talked about as a number and
dismissed because it takes away the
ability to balance bill which we all
want to get rid of however it doesn't
quantify the amount of money that the
providers are able to get by balance
billing in the addition to the rate
structure of the insurance
product it knocks it down in some cases
significantly for a number of providers
by bringing it to
200% I would argue or offer that if we
left it at the 325 per and did the
amendment and still did the study
committee with the cost data that that
may actually be something that would be
palatable to the majority of ambulance
providers because it would bring us to a
level where we know we could survive and
still provide cost data meaningful cost
data for the future to look at where we
need to be um I would suspect that the
insurers as they have all along would
vly oppose that including the insurance
commission for some reason um but I
think that that's something to consider
and that's something that we could
possibly live with now we've said this
before in the summit hearing and it
unfortunately fell on deaf ears so um
and again I'm I'm surmising because I
haven't seen this last minute amendment
to a Senate bill which is a little
strange in a public Hearing in the house
but um nonetheless um we're certainly
willing as a as a uh as an association
to take a look at things because we want
this to end to I've been here I've been
a paramedic for 40 years next month and
I've been here for the last 20 trying to
get this thing ended and we still
haven't managed to do it and I would
love to do that before I retire um so
that it's fair and Equitable and people
get the ambulance services that they
need and they don't sit and linger in
hospital beds waiting to be moved in an
emergency situation like they are now
that's not
right I'm happy to take any questions um
my testimony was going to be pretty much
everything you've already heard and
probably what you're going to hear in in
in the future and I think you know my
position so I'm in deference of time and
to the chairman I'm happy to answer any
questions okay representative Bros um
will the 325 per number be sufficient
for the rural ambulance uh services to
survive the way that this bill is
currently written it takes um there are
three rates that Medicare uses there's
an urban rate a rural rate and a super
rural rate which have multipliers
attached to them so um my understanding
and I would let Nate Borland from the
most super rural ambulance servers that
we have in the state at the 45th
parallel in colbrook speak to that
because he would know much better than I
does yes
repres basing on your name sorry it's
okay representer RoR thanks for taking
my question um it was mentioned that
there's new cost reporting that the feds
have set up and we plan the insurance
company plans to use that to get the
information how soon do you think a
sufficient number of uh reports would be
available with that
information I believe we are in year
four of a five-year cost study report
mandatory cost study report to CMS for
every ambulance provider in the United
States with the ultimate idea being to
rebase MediCare at some point and and
make it so that it actually does cover
the cost um covid like everything else
threw a wrench into that and delayed it
um but I believe we're in year four of
year five now many of the providers in
this room have probably probably already
done their cost reports I know we have
so thank you very oh represent
M thank Mr chairman thank you for taking
my question um what do EMTs and
paramedics in the state of New Hampshire
get paid I'm I'm hoping it's more than
the $7.75 an hour that I first made at
Rocky m i I think when you hired me I
can only speak for our organization um
the minimum starting wage for a basic
EMT is
about uh and I don't have the Union
contract in front of me it's about 21 or
$22 an hour um a paramedic starts out
around $35 an hour and an
aemt um you know makes somewhere in the
middle of that probably $25 $26 an hour
followup keep asking questions but we
want to get out of here at five I think
it helps put it in context what what the
good this might might do so thank you
for the followup uh thanks for taking
the followup would would the increase in
reimbursement help those wages you know
help the ambulance companies from
prevent them from going out of business
and help them perhaps increase the wages
of these these this staff I believe it
would we are we are not immune to the
workforce challenges that all of the
other health agencies and Public Safety
saf agencies I've I think we've got 25
or 30 open positions right now great
thanks for putting it in
context thank you thank you for your
time all right chair we'll call in
Anthem thank you chairman hunt and
members of the committee my name is
Sabrina Dunlap I'm director of
government relations for
Anthem um so I will I will try to keep
this quick um I have a few key points
I'd like to make so we're opposed to S
SP
407 um and on a process issue I just
want to respond if I could um to the
comment that carriers had not made an
offer until after the senate had already
passed the bill just as a point of
clarification on process the original
Senate bill that had a hearing um was
very different from the bill that's
before you it really addressed this
direct pay concept and then after the
hearing there were some conversations
behind the scenes but we did not see an
amendment until it was in Senate HHS in
an executive session so we actually this
is the first time we've gotten to
discuss publicly this concept of
325 of Medicare so in fact we had heard
that there could be something coming
down the pike in the Senate closer to
400% of Medicare so the carriers with
ahip did make a proposal um and I think
kidi croll will discuss that but it was
much closer to a main model which tries
to incentivize ambulances to come in
network um in any event I would also say
that as someone who was at I think every
single ambulance Summit meeting there
were many that the insurance department
organized we had many
discussions my memory is not ever that
we discuss something similar to what's
before you so speaking for Anthem I
think the other carriers would prob we
agree we were pretty surprised to see
this come forward as um a potential
solution um and you know I will I will
also comment that um we I think in these
discussions the carriers really
recognize the unique challenges that
ambulances face they they do have you
know this sort of distinct slice of
healthcare where they have to be 247
they're dealing with emergencies I am
involved in my local towns municipal
government I completely understand the
challenges um and also add in the fact
that there's a mix of private companies
and municipalities I mean that confuses
things so it's a very challenging part
of healthcare and I think we all
recognize that and we all came to those
meetings and sat in good faith and tried
to Hash this out because it has been a
conversation that's been going on for a
very long time um but I think it's
important to point out that one of the
tenants that we keep in mind uh one of
the tenants of Managed Care is the
concept of networks so while we
recognize the challenges facing
ambulance providers we also have to keep
sight of the importance of networks and
I do think that this bill would um
incentivize carriers to not only not
come in network but also to potentially
leave Network we do have a significant
number of ambulance providers in network
Anthem does in New Hampshire um and I
think what this bill would do is really
set kind of a default rate of 325 per of
Medicare um and so I think that is a
risk um I think that this undermines the
concept of networks and really takes us
in the wrong direction um and I also
would just say I don't think this bill
is good for our members it's not good
for consumers in New Hampshire there's
no ban on balance billing so an
ambulance provider can still charge
whatever they want above and beyond 325
of Medicare they will get that payment
from insurance companies and then
members could potentially be on the hook
for whatever else the ambulance charges
um and I think this this really at the
end of the day it's going to serve yes
it's a floor of
325 that's going to serve as really
functionally a mandate of reimbursements
being set at 325 per of Medicare that is
going to drive up costs for all
consumers I you heard the insurance
department say I think it was over $4
per member per month that is a
significant cost increase um so I think
you know this takes us in the wrong
direction in terms of building our
networks I don't think this is good for
consumers and certainly not good for our
members so thank you very much for
letting me testify and I'm happy to take
any
questions representative Sullivan has a
question thank you so I'm just I'm just
kind of curious now
so certain towns or certain ambulance
services aren't actually in your network
so what is the solution in your mind
then if somebody comes into a town
that's not in your network and then they
have some sort of emergency they get
hurt hiking up where I live or skiing at
Canon which is in myct district and
suddenly now that ambulance they can't
say no to them they can't reject them
and like like this seems like a real
problem and I get what you're
saying I mean it's not falling on dep
ears I feel you like it seems like
people probably will move out of network
at some level and maybe take the 350% or
whatever it is but like like what is
your solution just let ambulance
companies continue to lose money because
they're required to cover things and you
guys don't want to pay as much as
necessary like I don't get what solution
is here no I don't think that solution
is the solution I don't think any of the
carriers have said that this whole time
and thank you for the question I think
you're getting at the very difficult
thorny issues we've been trying to deal
with currently if an ambulance is out of
network um obviously we want our members
to have access to ambulances I you know
in my town we have made the commitment
that we will pay for 247 ambulance these
are decisions communities make Anthem
wants our members to have access to
ambulance so we recognize there's an
issue I don't think this bill is the
solution but to your question in that
case you know the ambulance company
would send a bill to Anthem and we would
pay the allowed amount for an out of
network provider if the ambulance was in
network that amount would be higher and
we wouldn't have to haggle around you
know them not having a contractual
relationship with us that's part of the
other challenge is out of network
ambulances we have no relationship with
them we have no contractual relationship
with them that is why we want them to be
in network so we have a relationship
with them and it's better for our
members F the question
inquire so what is the reasoning why
maybe you don't know and if you don't
that's fine but what is the reasoning
why a town would not want to be in
network if you're telling me that they
would get paid is it just a really
burdensome process to become in network
and so it's like these small towns of a
thousand people just can't do it like
what there has to be a reason if you
could make more money being in network I
think it's a very good question and I'm
not part of our Contracting networking
team but what I I'm guessing is and I
know for a fact that our Anthem team is
we are constantly making an effort to
bring more municipalities and providers
in network I think that New Hampshire
has so many small towns you have rural
areas and I think it is difficult I
think that you have to it requires
coming to the table and entering into a
contract you know and and there are
certain requirements to be in network
for the protection and benefit of our
members and so I think there there might
be some resistance to that I don't
really know the answer thank you did I
see represent Miku
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question is your town in
network and like what percentage of the
calls do do you guys represent so I'm
not here on behalf of my town so I I
don't want to speak on behalf of the
Hopkin and select board so I won't um
but I do think I believe our town is in
network
yes what percentage though of of what
percentage do you represent of of calls
of of all like ambulance business Anthem
or commercial insurance I don't know the
answer to that um but I will say I think
this brings up another important point
that I think others will probably speak
to which is we're talking about a big
problem and when we're talking about
just commercial insurance and again the
fully insured Market you're talking
about a tiny sliver of of who we're
covering in the state so I think I think
this Bill gets at sort of the wrong
group for the solution I think we're
part of the solution but this bill only
goes after commercial insurance and
fully insured people which is a very
state okay yeah representa ton
so an objection or a sticking point here
that I have been going all around this
bill is this uh subject of
U balance billing and I have trouble
understanding living in the rural part
of the state or semi- rural depending
upon where you are why there wouldn't
and maybe this isn't how the billing
works for an ambulance but I can
understand the floor being the 300% of
the Medicare rate but if I have to go up
two miles up a class six Road and haul a
300 P 300 PB man out of a building and
then back down again that's got to cost
me more than stopping in an apartment
building in a
garden apartment complex that's a half a
mile from the hospital so I would assume
that's where the balance billing comes
in is it unreasonable to Bill that
person that's my question thank you for
the question I I don't know how to
answer that exactly except I think this
sort of gets at another one of the
questions we really tried to tackle
during those ambulance Summit meetings
was let's get at why certain ambulance
Rides cost so much and it it probably is
a result of you have certain situations
that are more money and certain
situations that are easier and cost less
money but I I think it the balance
billing piece is very tough for members
because they get stuck with that bill
and that bill is coming from the
ambulance so there's a reason other
states have banned balance billing
consumers right I mean let's let's face
it the uh even with the fact that this
amendment this bill as we have coming
over still does not remove balance
billing is that that that they that the
whole reason we're here the whole reason
this has occurred it was around the
balance billing issue okay and that the
issue would be was that the ambulance
are saying is you're never going to you
know we're you know if we're in a fee
for service which is where our health
care is fee for service um we're never
going to we can't get what we really
need which is to pay for our people to
be hanging around waiting to service and
so therefore they have uh resisted um
any resolution here and you can see even
with this bill if there if the balance
billing is still in this bill it really
had never solved the ultimate problem
okay and that if the ultimate problem is
that they need more money you know in
terms of paying you know they're getting
the services what I would challenge is
and I will ask you those of you who are
in this crowd um you know if those of
you who have employers that are greater
than 100 employees are you telling me
that those orisa plans are paying you
more is anybody can tell me that Arisa
plans are paying more than what the the
small employer insurance
because if they're not I want to ask you
how would you like it if I told you
we're going to hit you with with $4 you
know was it $36 whatever we're you're
going to pay more health
insurance and it's only because you're
in the small group
Market only because you're in the small
group Market you're going to pay it if
you can't tell me that a large employers
are not paying more then I think you're
crazy not to take the the the uh
solution offer by the department it's a
compromise and me that's way you didn't
get it you got to take something and get
going because otherwise you know this
whole issue of holding off for balance
billing was based upon you wanted to get
fully paid and that is understandable
but at this point in time if if you w
expected to think you hit Independent
Insurance a small employer in health
insurance and say oh tag you're it
you're the one that's got to pay up the
difference the $1
million come on it's not
fair any more
questions thank
believe
okay uh chair ask for Ed Walker from
Peter
here we go thank you Mr chair um good
afternoon members of the committee I'm
Ed Walker I'm the fire chief and
ambulance service director for the town
of Peterborough I've been active in the
fire and Emergency Medical Services for
over 40 years 14 of which have spent
leading municipal fire departments with
a transport ambulance I'm here today to
urge you to support Senate Bill 407 and
act rela to pay for ambulance services
which seeks to compel insurance
companies to pay ambulance services
directly and sets a minimum payment or
floor as it's been referred to for
ambulance services in the state town of
Peterboro ambulance provides emergency
Transport service to over 13,000
residents in six communities as well as
emergency transports out of manad
Community Hospital a critical access
Hospital located within our community
last year we transported
1,494 patients in the past three years
we have transported a total of 212
patients that were paid to Patient
totaling over
$423,000 in charges these charges take
an average of 133 days for us to recover
significantly longer than is typical for
direct payments more importantly the pay
to Patient method of reimbursement to
Ence providers is confusing and
stressful to our patients an individual
who has experienced an accident or
medical emergency is often not able to
easily manage the barrage of bills and
payments they're not always aware of
what specific payment is intended to
cover of what Bill a specific payment is
intended to cover on multiple occasions
we have been forced to take individuals
we have been transported to small claims
court in an attempt to secure payment
payment that was paid to them directly
by their insurance company specifically
for the ambulance charge and not turned
over to us the second area addressed by
this bill is the establishment of a
reimbursement rate for medically
necessary ambulance services during the
past decade we have seen the percentage
of original charge paid by primary
Insurance fall from 43% to 33% while the
cost to deliver those Services has
significantly increased although
taxpayers in our service communities
contribute to the operating budget we
rely heavily on patient billing Revenue
to fund the service the establishment of
this minimum rate at 325 per of the
Medicare rate or the community
established rate whichever is lower
would provide a basis for reimbursement
that more closely represents the cost of
service delivery it will shift a larger
portion of those costs away from the
taxpayer and back back to those who are
receiving the services Senate Bill 407
if enacted would greatly ease the burden
of patients sorting out bills and
payments and help to ensure that
ambulance services are receiving
Insurance reimbursements in a timely
fashion and representative the cost to
Services thank you very much oh we do we
have a question I have a
question why do you not want to be in
network I mean Pro I I don't know if you
all have the same reason but I just
don't get
it so one one of the issues being a
network is what network do you get into
I'll pick Peterboro as an example
Peterboro is a community that has a lot
of retirees we have residents coming to
us that have we're fortunate um with our
payx um but when it comes to getting
into Network it's very difficult to
figure out what networks to join and the
network to go in and despite what the
insurance um the Anthem representative
said although a number of those folks
are paid a larger amount it's not a town
of Peterborough that does 1400 ambulance
transports year across dozens of
insurance companies we don't have the
ability to leverage we don't have the
ability to negotiate a fair rate a
larger Corporation that's doing National
transports of patients in you know major
metropolitan areas has that leverage we
do not nor do a lot of the other
providers in this room
today I understand we're talking about
the small group Market there's there's
only Anthem and Harvard there's only two
companies if you look at networks
nationally we we although this bill only
addresses your New Hampshire insurers
correct we are pro we are transporting
patients that have insurance from all
across the nation all kinds of different
providers so in terms of networks there
are a number of networks we aren't just
although we here within this hearing our
Focus just upon those commercial
insurers in New Hampshire that does not
represent all of the people that we
transport in ambulance in fact it
represents a very small percentage of
transport question represent spe I don't
know who knows the answer to this but I
have my local doctor he belongs to I
don't know how many
networks surely a doctor that has a
small practice or a group of doctors
that have a small practice if they're
able to handle being in multiple
networks I'm not clear on why you can't
I think the other one of the other
problems you get back to and um the
Ambulance Association May able to
address this better than I am you select
your doctor based upon your network an
individual having a medical emergency
cannot select their ambulance they can't
choose to go Two Towns over to get
transported because that ambulance
service is in the network that they're a
part
of that that's really not quite true
right we we select our doctor based on
who we know but I know I belong over to
the small Clinic over by Harvard
Pilgrim they it doesn't make any
difference who your insurance is they're
in the network I and including Medicare
I I'm just not clear on on why you think
you can't do that and we're talking
about New Hampshire we're not talking
about the rest of the world we're just
talking about New Hampshire because
that's the only place we have control
over
I understand I I it's the only place
we've control however it's not the only
place that our patients are insured
from we're not talking about just the
small group employers here we're talking
about literally dozens of insurance
companies across every state in this
country right and what we're trying to
tell you is that if it isn't
Anthem or
Harvard this legislation doesn't affect
them this legislation only affects
small group small employer
Insurance in the state of New Hampshire
and that's two
companies the one benefit this bill does
is establishing that as they're
referring to at the floor rate one of
the problems that we face on a routine
basis is adjudicating claims based upon
what is considered to be a fair and
reasonable amount for the ambulance bill
if the legislature in New Hampshire were
to determine that 325 per of Medicare is
a reasonable and a fair rate for that
emergency ambulance bill it would
significantly help us in the educating
of those bills as well as justifying
that rate when dealing with the
patients
okay all right
chair we call on U so we have got
permission to stay after five okay so uh
Dave Emanuel
cheese
don't so for the members you if you want
to take off um they they'll leave the
YouTube camera on so you can tune in
while
you're have your
dinner but I will stay here and go
through this chair pres H thank you for
your time my name is Dave Emanuel I
appear before you as president of the
New Hampshire Association of Fire Chiefs
I serve as a fire chief of the town of
Durham on the University of New
Hampshire campus the New Hampshire
Association of Fire Chiefs provides
leadership education and advocacy for
the New Hampshire fire service on behalf
of the Association members we would like
to express our support for Senate Bill
407 Rel relative to direct pay for
ambulance providers what we had done
over the past couple years working with
the work group studying this material is
we have collected collected data from 42
communities representing almost 50,000
EMS transports in the state of New
Hampshire and weed data that
demonstrated the vast majority of
communities that provide ambulet
services to not recover their costs for
providing that service that means the
costs born are by the local property
taxpayers we understand what you're
wrestling with today and we know that
the New Hampshire Association of Fire
Chiefs has been actively engaged on the
work groups to try to address these
challenges we're not familiar with the
amendment that's been brought forward
today and but we do know that 200% of
Medicare rates is inadequate for a
fire-based EMS Transport Service in the
state of New Hampshire the fees that are
not covered go back to the balance
billing to make the wheels turn for the
municipalities because it it either goes
back to the person who's being
transported or the community that runs
the EMS service I appreciate your time
and consideration um and from the
feedback from our members from the fire
departments that provide EMS transport
service that are not in network they
they can't negotiate a rate that covers
their services for the Network rates
that was the to answer the question that
was made earlier about why aren't all
the fire departments in the rate in the
network they can't afford to do it to
cover the community I I'm grateful for
your time today thank you
sir thank you very
much chair we call on Heidi CW I'm May
here
um good evening Mr chairman and members
of the committee I'm for the record my
name is Heidi croll I work at Gallagher
cahan gartrell and I represent ahip
which is America's health insurance
plans um so I appreciate um the
opportunity to testify today I
appreciate the the late hour that it is
um ahip is um opposed to S SP 407 as
amended by the sen
um and I do appreciate the opportunity
to testify on this bill um uh the bill
was amended amended um substantially um
from its uh as introduced version in the
Senate but the Amendments uh never did
have a public hearing there um there was
an amendment in introduced at the time
that the Senate HHS had an executive
session um that was voted on the same
day and um then the bill went to the
Senate finance committee where it was
amended again um also with an amendment
introduced uh during the executive
session that did not get a a public
hearing there as well so and that um
carriers had not seen these amendments
so um I did have several conversations
with the prime sponsor as well as other
Senators about the bill um during that
period between um the bill being an HHS
um and being in Senate Finance but
obviously those conversations are not a
a substitute for public hearings on a um
such very significant amendments um so s
SP 407 proposes to take New Hampshire
down the path for the first time ever
really of local government setting
mandatory minimum rates for emergency
ambulance services that carriers would
be required to pay and that are
effectively set at an arbitrary rate of
325 per of Medicare um it's 325 per is
arbitrary and then it lacks any New
Hampshire specific Actuarial or other
evidentiary uh Foundation um and in
addition to mandating that New Hampshire
employers and individuals pay this
arbitrary minimum charge of 325 per of
Medicare enroles in fully insured plans
will still be at risk of balance billing
because um as you've heard the bill does
not ban um that practice so that's a
little preview of ahip's um serious
concerns with the bill um but before I
get into the details I wanted to share
some important background and context
with you um so first of all emergency
ambulance services do represent a unique
intersection between Public Safety and
Health Care um both ta taxpayers and the
various health insurance payers whether
it's Medicaid Medicare commercial plans
um should play a role in supporting
these Public Services um support should
not be expected in our opinion to come
exclusively from the various payers um
local taxpayers pay for police they pay
for fire um and they should share at
least some responsibility um for paying
for ambulance services as well and I
point that out um simply to make sure
that uh you know to the extent that
people are thinking that 100% of
ambulance service cost should be paid um
simply by Insurance payers um we would
respectfully disagree with that um the
second point I want to make is that the
highest reimbursement rates that
ambulance providers receive today um do
come from Private health insurance plans
um namely those plans that are paid for
by New Hampshire businesses and
individual citizens Medicaid Medicare
and unassured payers are all paying
significantly less than private plans do
um third as you know um there are
self-funded plans those like what the
state offers um uh to its employees and
retirees or l employers offer and there
are fully insured plans those that
individuals and small to midsize
employers purchase um from insurance
companies and the bill as you know um if
you've heard only applies to fully
insured plans not to self-funded plans
and definitely not to Medicaid or
Medicare so um approximately 28% of the
market is served by fully insured plans
in the individual employer markets
approximately 34% is served by
self-funded plans and the rest of the
market is Medicaid Medicare and other
government programs um so as the point
has been made um the impacts of this
bill will be borne solely by the New
Hampshire citizens who purchase their
health insurance in the individual
market and by employers located in New
Hampshire that purchase fully insured
plans and it again is their plans that
are already paying more than Medicaid
and Medicare for ambulance services um
the fourth point I would like to make is
that the insurance department as you've
heard did convene um this ambulance
Summit um back last late last summer
where it pulled together a group of
stakeholders um ambulance providers
carriers other um others interested um
to look at the ambulance uh
reimbursement and the role of the fully
insured plans play in that the group met
a number of times and also created three
or four subgroups that also met a number
of times and i' say we probably met at
least a dozen times Al together maybe
more um and you know not once during
that process did the ambulance providers
suggest the proposal that is um set
forth in s SP 407 it wasn't mentioned it
wasn't vetted um with that group which
was specifically convened for the
purpose of exploring different ideas
about um ambulance reimbursement by
fully insured plans the fifth and final
point I would like to make before I get
into the details of the bill is that
when you look at the types of payers to
whom ambulance providers are sending
their bills less than 10% of that payer
mix is the fully insured market so again
less than 10% and I did circulate around
a pie chart that shows this um the
remaining 90 plus% of the payers that
are getting bills from ambulance
providers are Medicaid Medicare Tricare
the uninsured um with Medicaid and
Medicare being the two um biggest um
totaling
77% so I mentioned this because the
financial challenges that ambulance
providers face is largely driven by the
low reimbursement rate from the that
largest group of payers um Medicaid and
Medicare so now I'd like to turn to the
specifics of ES B 407 as amended um
section one Roman 1 of sb47 requires the
carriers to pay ambulance providers
directly no sending checks to the
patients um as uh to the extent that's
even happening anymore um carriers are
not opposed to that provision um and as
you know that's a statutory provision
also accomplished in House Bill 1081
which you um passed here passed out of
committee um and is now in the Senate uh
Senate HHS committee um
section one Roman one of of the bill
also requires carriers to pay out of
network ambulance providers for
emergency transports at either rate set
by the local government um or contracted
entity subject to a public process or
325 per of medicare's rates whichever is
less um our concern is that this new
mandate would insert um government
intervention and really local government
intervention into private contract
negotiations between carriers and
ambulance providers and establish uh
Government rate setting um in Private
health insurance really for the first
time in New Hampshire um the Practical
effect we think of this bill will be a
government imposed minimum charge
mandate set at 325 per of Medicare and I
think actually you've heard that from
some of the providers as well um and so
what will happen is that any
municipality whose emergency ambulance
charges are currently below 325 per of
Medicare We Believe will raise their
their charges to equal 325 ofic care the
reason is simple um they will not want
to leave money on the table um if that
law if the law allows them to collect
charges set at 325 per. um they may
increase their charges um to pay for new
equipment new staff um benefits or the
like but the point is that there will be
you know um no incentive to uh contain
cost below the 325 per um Mark Benchmark
um we're also concerned that the local
rates will shift um will will result in
cost shifting onto fully insured plans
which again are the part that's less
than 10% of the ambulance providers
service base um as I mentioned earlier
um and so it's those premium payers will
be left and our Our concern is left
subsidizing Medicare and Medicaid um and
the other government group programs um
through higher premiums higher
deductibles or higher cost sharing um
and when people are in their deductible
phase of their insurance they will will
be paying the 325 of Medicaid directly
um again with no protection against
balance
billing um another effect of this bill
is that any ambulance provider who is
currently in necor getting reimbursed um
pursuant to uh the negotiated rates um
will likely seek rates that are above
325 per of Medicare um as a condition of
staying in network otherwise they will
just leave the network um and go get
paid 325 of Medicare and retain the
ability to B balance Bill the patient so
again if you're in network you're
prohibited by state law to balance Bill
if you're out of a network um they have
the ability to balance bill um so that
could be another incentive that's
keeping um the providers out of network
um and I had initially thought that this
applied only to outof network providers
but um there's some language in here um
in particular on lines 14 and 15 which
makes me think and it says or according
to the participating ambulance providers
build charges whichever is the lesser
amount so I think that somehow um the in
network providers are also getting
pulled into this and um allow to have
their charges or 325 per.
[Music]
um finally Our concern is um if you pass
this bill we are concerned that starting
next year it's potentially uh or maybe
even quite likely the other providers in
New Hampshire from large Hospital
Systems down to small providers will
come to the legislature looking for
state government to guarantee them a
minimum of 25% of Medicare as well
um we've heard we've talked about um the
fact that 325 per is arbitrary um so
I'll uh skip over that
um and just would like to emphasize that
you know nowhere else in New Hampshire's
commercial health insurance markets our
providers guaranteed a statutory rate
guarantee where they can you know
essentially demand be paid a minimum of
325 of Medicare and the carriers have to
pay it um and that really becomes a
ceiling uh I mean a floor um not a
ceiling um just a few more points um in
the Roman three um of this bill it says
that in the event of a dispute between
the health provider and insurer um uh
there's a dispute resolution process
which um you know as you heard this
morning with s SP 173 that's going to be
changed kind of being the state level
new hampsh uh no surprises act um and I
think it's just a little ironic that um
ground ambulance providers have
successfully um Exempted themselves or
kind of been you know kept out of um
advocated to be kept out of the um no
surprises act um and we actually
wouldn't need s SP 407 if they were
included under the federal no surprises
act so um it would solve a lot of the a
lot of the problems um and of course the
surprises act does include a Prohibition
on balance
billing um I would call your attention
to the um the fiscal note in the bill um
and I can just quote it quickly here but
you've heard you know it's going to 11.8
million or
$441 per member per month and then the
department assumes for Riders would
migrate to the 325 per of Medicare rate
rather than to negotiate a lower rate
and so again that 11.8 million is
assuming that the providers get um their
charges
um uh and one of the other um handouts
that I gave to you is um the median
build amounts or charges by the ground
ambulance providers as a percentage of
Medicare rates um actual versus proposed
under SP 407 so this information came
out of the Department's um uh report
their ambulance summer Summit report um
and the purpose of this handout is
simply to show you that one provider's
um current bill charges as a percentage
of Medicare
um uh you will see that in six of the
nine billing code categories um their
Bild charges are actually below 32%
which means that in six of those nine
categories it would go up
um and the final point I would just say
is um you know during the period between
when um this bill was had come out of
the Senate HH committee and was on its
way to Senate Finance um as you heard
during one of the calls that the
carriers had with the prime sponsor of
the bill and and one of The Advocates
the carriers were um criticized for not
having put forth a concrete proposal
during the ambulance Summit meetings um
which I think we found a little
interesting because I'm not sure that
they put forward a concrete proposal
either but at any rate we took that
comment seriously and we actually did
submit to them um a proposal um which I
I guess um they never responded to it so
I guess it um wasn't one that they were
interested in um but it would have
required um direct pay by the health
insurance carriers to the ambulance
providers it would have Pro prohibited
balance billing it would have required
um carriers to directly pay 180% of
Medicare to out of network providers
200% of Medicare to in network providers
um or the provider's bill charges
whichever is less um and again this is
for um the unscheduled or emergency
ambulance transports um it was modeled
after uh the law in Maine um and from
our perspective would have represented a
significant and E economically ad uh
advantageous increase in payments um
from the fully insured health plans to a
municipal and private um ground
ambulance providers especially the ones
operating in New Hampshire's Rural and C
rural areas um so in closing we um are
our opposed s SP 407 and we would um
encourage you to find it inexpedient to
legislate and I'd be happy to try to
answer any
questions represent
spear you obviously have a lot of this
written down is there any chance you
could send it to us there's no way I
could have written that fast I'll try to
clean it up it's just my my notes but I
would be happy to do that I appreciate
it representative pelli so I I fully
appreciate the issue and I really want
to thank everybody here here today we we
want a a EMT when we need one so I
really appreciate all of you however
this is a really complicated issue so
this is I'm assuming this is a
nationwide problem are there any states
that
have um solve this issue or don't not
have these problem these billing
problems do you know of um I think it is
um probably a nationwide problem and I
think it stems prod dominantly from
Medicare and to some extent Medicaid
underpaying um and of course the
uninsured um uh
so so I do think it's probably a problem
that we see nationally um there are a a
handful of states that um are trying to
tackle this um in ways like Maine or
ways like you see in this bill um they
are all very very new um and there's not
the experience to see how they will work
um if they will work um and what sort of
unintended consequences there might be
and they are all very they should at
least be in my in our opinion um State
specific because each state has its own
just unique features just a quick
clarifying question so the pie chart was
very helpful so because Medicare and
Medicaid rates are so significantly low
we're asking the fully insured Market to
try to make up for the shortfalls of
Medicare and Medicaid is that how I'm
that's what we're concerned about yes
okay thank
you representa m thank you Mr chairman
thank you for taking my question so on
how about on the um insurance department
Amendment have did you see it so I for
today or I just found out about it today
um as well and and I was given a copy
after Alex testified but I haven't had a
chance to take a look at it so I it
sounds to me like it parallels the um
Department's report um in their
recommendation
but I would have to take a closer look
at it B based on the experience in the
five states that have sounds like it's
similar to the five states that have
passed
it do you have any comment on those
those States or would you guys support
it I'm really I'm I'm I'll try to get an
answer for you but I don't have one this
afternoon okay I think the problem right
now is the balance billing well we heard
the amendment prohibits that is 325 with
no balance billing
and I think that's what they I think
that's what they did in the other five
states or at least five were four were
325 one was 400 but I'll have to check
and see if there balance billing I I can
I can address at least that that my from
what I've seen um every other state
that's tried to tackle this has banned
balance billing everybody
else doesn't no the amendment does and
and we heard in testimony that they'd be
okay with 325 and no balance billing who
who was okay with that I believe Mr STW
was said they that he he said in his
testimony they'd be okay with Banning
balance billing in fact he said they
want to ban balance billing but they
need 325 to make it a okay business
model to do it I'm sure he did I guess
we'll have to watch the tape on that one
I'm sure I'm sure he did okay
represent I just have a really simple
question um so the P the pie chart that
you passed
out uh three4 of the pie chart would pay
a third less than a third of this
uh I'm trying to frame the question in
the simplest way possible so if this
goes through the private insured which
is about 20 25% would pay three
times three and a quarter times what
Medicare and Medicaid is paying out for
the same exact service that's a correct
to so it would be 100% of Medicare is
what's being paid by Medicare and with
the budget that was passed last um June
um Med medic my understanding is that
the Medicaid rate increase um which I
think the state put in something like
$5.7 million I think that gets matched
federally so you know something close to
in the 11 to 12 million range additional
Medicaid funds um which my understanding
is that that brings Medicaid relatively
on par with what Medicare pays um so yes
100% of Medicare um but just one point
of clarification on what you said um the
only um part of that pie that this bill
targets is the 10% the fully insured
Market um in individual market and the
small employer so it doesn't um you know
there's kind of two parts to Commercial
Insurance there's the fully insured and
the self-funded um and of course we
can't touch self-funded with state laws
so um it's from the perspective of the
bills going out from the ambulance
providers and that that information came
from one of the ambulance providers um
during the ambulance Summit the data
that's in that Pi so they said that
somewhere between 15 and 20% of their
payer mix was commercial and that
includes both self-funded and fully
insured and So based on what we know
about those Dynamics in our Market it's
under 10% for fully insured quick follow
forther question me inquire just so I
understand the self-funded portion which
is 10% of this pie what rates do they
pay and how are they determined it's a
good question I don't have specific
information on that but I would guess
that it's probably relatively close to
what the um what the fully insured um
payers pay
um there's just because of
the a lot of carriers will act as a
third-party administrator to those
self-funded plans so even though they're
taking the risk and they're paying the
cost they hire a carrier to actually do
the administrative work and so they look
to the carriers for a lot of guidance
around appropriate reimbursement um so
if I had to guess I'd say they're
probably
close right if we take any experience of
the state is uh anything we mandate here
the state eventually picks up so
theoretically that that I would manage I
believe Anthem manages the state's plan
right that's correct right so I I I you
know's left the room but I I think that
it's probably uh the rates that that
they use the same scenario so that's why
they're hoping that if we pass this 325
then all those Arisa plans and like the
state or the county will jump in and pay
the the extra rate but again we can't we
can't mandate that and so I think you
know from a from a um from the
perspective of the business Community
this is kind of piling on those small
and midsize businesses that are
purchasing fully insured products and
creating an UNL playing field because on
the you know the the ones that are large
enough to sell fund wouldn't be under
this mandate you have a question
represent M just really really quick
since the you expressed some reservation
about what happened in the Senate with
the amendment no public hearing or
whatnot and kind of the same thing is
going on here we got an amendment we've
got a subcommittee tomorrow planning on
executing it later in the day
tomorrow so can we you wouldn't have the
same reservation
if we look at this amendment work on it
tomorrow EXA tomorrow I I would hope
that you would retain this bill for some
further study um that would be you know
I mean I'm recom we're you know our
recommendation officially is you know
itl but if you know it clearly needs
more work um our reservation in the
Senate was that the amendment came in
during the Senate HHS executive session
um it was not an amendment that we had
seen um and I don't I don't believe
others had seen either it was exact that
day um Without Really any discussion the
focus at that executive session was on
the direct pay piece because that was
the underlying original bill um but this
was obviously substantially different
you've been here a long time amendments
come in all the time and get exact same
day all the time so and this is a
problem we've dealt with a long
time not in this committee Mr chairman
you bringing amendments all all the time
at the last minute and we exec them
forth with no I don't the few amendments
we've had were tiny that before we exact
AR to respond to your question we we
fully appreciate a full and open process
bodies thank you very much for your
testimony okay that's uh Drew Klein I
going the wrong
way Mr chairman members of the committee
thank you uh for the opportunity to
testify I'm Drew Lon I'm president of
the Josiah baret Center for Public
Policy New Hampshire's free market Think
Tank and although I hate to be on the
opposite side of an issue from Chris STW
who's a great guy um we look at this
bill and just the way it's written I
know it's a complicated problem and it's
something the state's been trying to
solve for a long time and it and it
screams out for some type of solution
but the way this bill is written uh as
we look at it it it really does create
kind of a a default floor uh for
these prices by the way it's structured
is says you can reimburse for um one of
three different rates right the
negotiated rate the build rate or 325 of
Medicaid that one is set so you know
what the 325 per of Medicaid is so what
the effects of this will
do just basic economic theory at work
why would anyone negotiate any rate that
is lower than 325 of federal poerty
level it's a very high percentage it's
arbitrarily chosen you heard from the
insurance department it's much higher
than what um is being paid in many cases
we looked at the insurance Department's
numbers with median rates for different
services that they just published uh
last month and um there are quite a few
services in the rural part of the state
that are well below 325
of the Medicare rate so we look at this
and go you're likely to
increase prices uh in rural areas in New
Hampshire because of this the way this
bill is structured so we just say this
is probably not the best way to go about
fixing this problem the problem in the
ambulance price um and billing model is
that you just you don't have a
competitive market so there's no way for
the consumer to know what the price is
what they're going to get built for I
mean that's That's the basis of problem
then you got Medicare that you know pays
an arbitrarily low rate so you know all
the all that um there are ways you can
sort of try to approximate a market um
when you don't have one and one can't be
created picking a number um you know
because a few other states did it and
just inserting into law which will
require more legislative work to change
if that turns out not to be the best
number it's just really um not the most
effective way to do it and I think it
will end up leading to price increases
across the board so that's
all thank you very much chair will call
lemon thank you this is my first time
doing this good evening so uh my name is
Chris Lumin I'm the executive director
for McGregor EMS we're a nonprofit uh
ambulance service located in Durham New
Hampshire uh we're a little bit unique
uh in that we have about 30,000 hour we
have a lot of volunteers who give about
30,000 hours of commun of time to the
communities every year and so I want to
speak to a question that's been raised a
couple of times about why would McGregor
choose not to be in network with these
insurance companies and this was
something we worked very closely with
the communities uh that we serve uh and
have a a very transparent process and
one of the benefits to being a nonprofit
uh is that and you know being so
Community Based is that because our
budget is open one of the things I've
said to the uh anthem when I've reached
out to them on multiple occasions is
listen I can't make ends meet with what
you're offering but i' love to have a
conversation we'll show you what our
costs are in spite of all this volunteer
time in spite of being a nonprofit
um and I can you work with me and
they've said no they cannot now I
reached out to them when this process
began when this legislation started to
be talked about and of course there's
work at the federal level as well
thinking gez maybe we will see some
progress on this right maybe this is the
time when minds are being changed and
big surprise Anam said well you know
we've increased what we're offering
quite a bit but we're still not willing
to talk to you we're still not willing
to work with you at the end of the day
if McGregor were to go in service or uh
in network with uh
Anthem um it would end up being a loss
of money for us and what that would mean
is that then I'd be turning around and
going back to the four communities that
I serve uh within New Hampshire and
asking them to pitch in more money for
the service uh so there's been a lot of
question about you know why are we not
working with uh with the insurance
company I've not been at the table that
uh some of these other pieces you know
these other groups have been talking
about but I would say that I'm not as
experienced as many of the people here I
only have 22 years of doing this but uh
you know I didn't become an EMT I didn't
become a nurse uh so I could be messing
over patients and because of my role I'm
the one that takes the phone calls from
the patients when they are stuck in the
middle and we work with them on that but
it is a very frustrating uh process C
and it's a very confusing process for
the patients because of this getting
getting this check I would also just
note that Anthem is the only insurance
company that we work with regularly that
does that that sends the check directly
to the patient uh so the notion that you
know they can't send us the check
directly because we don't have a
contractual relationship seems a little
disingenuous to me the last thing I will
just share is that um we are a small
employer as well and so you know our
it's it's all always a double-edged
sword right because I pull my hair out
when I see the uh insurance rates go up
every year and then I pull my hair out
because uh and I don't have a lot of
hair uh when uh you know we're trying to
make ends meet in terms of our budget uh
but this seems like a small price to pay
for from a small insurer perspective to
ensure that uh if I have a medical
up representative spear has a question
so if the rate was
325 of Medicare but you couldn't balance
Bill how does that said with you so I
can only speak for my for my
organization myself that would uh put us
in a we could that would be
fine thank you we could make ends meet
we could not make ends meet and I would
have to go back and do the do the math
but I have a general sense of the rates
I'd be very shocked uh and I haven't
done the mass specifically but it what
was proposed earlier today is not
Boran thank you Mr chairman it's good to
see you
again ladies and gentlemen I'm going to
apologize to you in Advance according to
my children when I'm passionate on an
issue I get unintentional angry voice so
if I seem like I'm fired up I apologize
in advance uh I had a very well worded
speech all prepared for you and there's
been enough testimony now that that's
out the window completely so you'll have
to bear with me a little bit uh doubling
down on what Chris just said the in
network issue that you guys are focusing
on there is no benefit to me at all in
our organization uh at 45th parallel EMS
there's no benefit whatsoever to being
in their Network at this current time
they offer us minuscule 160% of Medicare
and that does not come anywhere near
covering our cost of operation up north
not at all we represent the hardest
demographic to cover in basically in the
entire country we have a huge coverage
area we cover 57 miles the last 57 miles
of Route three from one station with two
trucks we C cover a land mass the size
of the State of Rhode Island and we have
a population base of about 8,000 people
to draw from most of our calls are
transient people coming into the area to
snowmobile four-wheel hunt those kinds
of things so I don't have a huge tax
base to draw from and last year I asked
my 8,000 taxpayers in the poorest
demographic in this state to fund us 3/4
of a million dollars to operate our
business 911 calls we do last year we
did 871 911 calls about 30% of those
were non- transports that we cannot bill
for under current statute so we build
for somewhere over 500 911 calls total
to fund our entire
operation uh of that our reimbursement
was about
$327,000 if I remember correctly that
doesn't even pay for one truck much less
the two that we staff that doesn't even
come close when you consider that the
cost of a current ambulance is
$240,000 the cardiac monitor sitting in
that ambulance is
$50,000 all fully wrapped an ALS
ambulance is4 to $500,000 by the time
you get all of the equipment and
everything in it just to start it and
get it on the road and then there's the
payroll issue you know the question was
asked what the average EMT or or
paramedic earns we can't compete with
some of the r r that they're paying down
here uh we're closer than I thought I
was very impressed with our numbers when
I heard Chris talking but we're not
there you know we're we're paying 16 to
35 an hour depending on certification
and
qualifications and some of us myself
included are putting in literally a 100
hours a week to make things work because
we're so short staffed uh and during the
eclipse as a matter of fact I personally
put in 128 Hours that week There's 168
hours in the week you're starting to see
the picture what my life looks like
right
now so the concept of you know 160% of
Medicare or 180% of Medicare or 200% of
Medicare just does not pay my operating
costs I don't expect the insurance
companies to pick up all of the costs I
do not but you're addressing some of the
others you've addressed the Medicaid
reimbursement already thank you for that
that is a help CMS is addressing the
Medicare issue the it's they're taking
their time because it's the federal
government but they're working on it so
we have to address this piece as well no
we're not looking for the insurance
companies to fund absolutely everything
but they have to do their part and they
have not for a very long time they have
been running all of our bills through
this algorithm that they have that we
can't even get a look at and repricing
saying well we believe that it costs
this amount of dollars to cover
ambulance services in the state of New
Hampshire and my you know 500 calls that
I've build out really does not offset
the call volume in the southern half of
the state so my numbers aren't even
factored into this so they tell me your
bill for $1,500 should actually be you
know $800 and that's what we're paying
you and you have no recourse to uh try
to argue this at all none anytime you
call you get put on hold for 45 minutes
you get kicked around to three different
people and then the last person that
picks up the phone disconnects
accidentally and you start over
so what am I supposed to
do how how am I supposed to fix this I'm
already going after my taxpayers for
$750,000 a year we have added that
second truck to be able to take as many
interfacility transports out of
everywhere that we possibly can to add
additional Revenue to not have to go
after our taxpayers we come as far south
as spear in Plymouth and Memorial over
in North Conway so our trucks are on the
road for 2 hours before they even get to
a patient just to grab extra Revenue
where we can to fund our operation I
can't push that any further I can't say
Hey you know go down to Mass General and
pick up a patient and be on the road for
the next 14 hours because that doesn't
make Financial sense either so I'm
really stuck in a position where if we
don't do something and do something soon
I'm going to be forced to do one of two
things I'm going to be forced to either
cut services that we provide or go after
our taxpayers for for more money and
again this is the most rural section of
this state and the most impoverished
area so I don't feel right going to them
and asking hey you know I know you're
barely getting by on $20,000 a year but
you're going to have to pay me an extra
500 bucks this next year just to provide
services to you that you may or may not
need I can't increase our call volume it
is what it is unless we can start
figuring out how people can schedule
their emergencies better uh in which
case that fixes my Staffing problem too
little humor there by the way
so I'm kind of stuck this is what I have
to work with so we really desperately
need your help in fixing all avenues of
this and getting you know the funding
that we need to stay operational if any
of you come up into my coverage area and
you know have a four-wheeler accident or
have a heart attack or anything like
that I want to be there to be able to
help you make sure you get to where you
need to be and you're also not burdened
with a huge bill because you're insured
so I actually found myself agreeing in
part which surprised me with some of the
insurance lobbyists that are here that I
don't like balance billing either I
don't like making that phone call that
hey you know you've got a bill here to
pay and the insurance company has told
them no we've paid this and you're not
responsible for that extra amount and
we're saying yes they are so the
patients are getting confused and we
have to go after people that I don't
want to have to go after because they're
not being reimbursed properly so I
believe it was your question about 325
of Medicare and balance billing again
speaking only for my organization having
just looked at the numbers if they're
paying 325 I'm not balance Billing at
all I don't have to that ends that
problem at least for our
patients
um let's see what else do I have for
notes I think that's pretty well um
everything that I had running through my
head at this point I'll certainly take
any questions that you have and do my
yeah represent thank you Mr chair thank
you for taking our questions um this was
uh passed out by uh ahip I believe um it
says that the super rural rate uh is
somewhere between 160 and 200% of
Medicaid already is that uh a rate set
by you or is it the rate that's cently
set by CMS the the super rural uh it's
something that they vote on and they've
added in uh for several years uh it
comes up for revote every few years as
to whether they're going to continue to
reauthorize this or Not So currently
you're getting 160 to 200% of Medicare I
believe it's closer to the 160 yes and
uh and then your balance billing on top
of it if necessary we can't balance Bill
uh Medicare or Medicaid we can only
balance Bill insurance companies
Medicare and Medicaid we take what they
give us um Medicare sometimes they have
a $250 co-pay but for the most part CMS
regulated um insurances we take what
they they pay and that's it okay thank
you so the balance billing issue is
really only a commercial insurance issue
correct okay thank you very much thank
you
uh Derek
it again thank you um thank you chairman
hunt and uh members of the New Hampshire
Commerce and consumer affairs committee
my name is Derek alond I live in hookit
and I represent the New Hampshire amland
Association I'm not going to go over
there's a lot of good testimony today
you know based on what has been said um
from you know whether Senator Apprentice
Chris St was um Chris lemlin Etc even in
some cases you know there was some
surprising um testimony come from from
the insurance industry I just really
want to reemphasize the uh you know how
unique the provision of EMS is and why
we have the problem that we have today
you know because you can't compare EMS
and Manchester to just as the example
that you got from Nate all the way up
there in colbrook you can't you know
explain the difference just from call to
call you know there was an example given
earlier about the person that has to be
carried down three flights of stairs you
know and they weigh 300 00 lb to the
person that very quickly can be
extricated off a um you know the side of
the road you know it is a very complex
industry and you know we don't get to
choose our patients we don't get to
choose our payers we don't get to choose
how we're paid or when we're paid um
these are all problems that plag us and
certainly um I'm not going to go over
the in the network issue again you know
it is you know my own experience and the
experiences that the association has
heard from his members that they've
tried to go in network and they've just
been offered a rate that is take it or
leave it
um and just to go over a couple things
that were not touched on um you know our
industry is heavily regulated and I
think that that's one of those things
that you know has only been touched on
briefly on the surface you know whether
it's the um Bureau of EMS right here in
town um that you know providing
regulations or local medical control
that are saying you know these are the
things that you must provide and some of
the um examples that were given were
ambulances that you know we you just
can't throw a rusty truck on the road
you know you have to buy a truck and you
know they've gone up exponentially I
personally my service you know ourland
truck that were taking delivery that we
waited now three years for next week is
showing up 4400 and something thousand
and that is before you put in a cardiac
monitor that is before you put in all
the other equipment that is frankly
expected when the um ambulance is called
you know the person dials 911 and I love
the 911 program that we have here in
their state they are expecting that
person to show up and that crew to show
up up and have the best equipment have
the best training and be available 24
hours a day be available whether it's at
2:00 in the afternoon when everybody's
around or 2 o'clock in the morning when
you know there's people have just been
waiting and you've heard about the cost
of Readiness I'm not going to waste your
time and go over that again but it is
expensive um just to touch on some uh
really quick other things you know the
opinion of the association is that the
insurance company should not be in the
business of dictating how much an
ambulance service trip should cost in
New Hampshire that should a local
control and that's what we're asking for
you know the the local decision by local
officials the insurance industry
strategy will limit access and take away
local control and it will
disproportionately impact rural
communities as my friend Nate just
mentioned um finally just to go over a
couple things and to clear things up you
know Medicare people are talking about
the basic rates of Medicare you know
Medicare 20 years ago and you can go to
your own research and look at the May
report from 2007 Medicare was upwards of
14% below the cost of ambulance doing
business and I can assure you Medicare
has not kept up you know so those costs
are not reflective of Medicare we're
even now Medicaid and we do appreciate
the relief that we received but we are
not you know being compensated in order
to provide that service that frankly the
citizens demand you know they want that
ambulance to be there 24 hours a day
whether they know it or not and and they
frankly expect it having taken those 911
calls myself um just so some uh you know
we have services that are going out of
business because of these you know there
are you know you just need to look at
the paper and look in Keen you know a
service going out of business there you
look in Guilford there service going out
of business there and it is directly as
the result of their reimbursements
they're not able to keep up with costs
you know primarily because of super Roll
and Roll problems but yes because of the
costs um and somebody had talked about
you know I believe it was one of the um
representatives from the insurance
agencies talking about how Main the
problem or what exact language was Maine
ended up having despite what their
legislation having to infuse money into
the local EMS Services because their
regulations did not cover it they ended
effectively I think that's really all I
have other than to say
um is there any questions that I can
group yes R thank you for taking my
question I live in Manchester and uh so
I know when I call 911 I mean the
ambulance is going to be there like
immediately if I don't live in manchest
I live you know in a rural Town who gets
the call are you talking about the
original call the 911 call yeah so man'
I guess it's dispatched okay you
actually have a very robust and um great
system here that's actually pretty
unique I worked for it the state of New
Hampshire 911 program yep and when you
dial 911 regardless of where you are in
the state it rings and conquered they
have a secondary peap in lonia but it
rings and conquered and then no matter
what time of day you get your care it
starts when that phone rings yep I'm a
strong proponent of that you get your
care immediately somebody's giving CPR
instructions somebody's telling somebody
how to give Naran somebody is telling
somebody how to you know alleviate
choking within seconds of that phone
ringing within that emergency but there
is still that delay of you know that
ambulance responding so that and that
that call will then get transferred I'll
my New London is the area that I cover
New London dispatch dispatches for that
area so they will have that call come in
to them Manchester we go to Manchester
fire Etc right thanks a lot of course
ma'am very much thank you sir very much
say Thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee recognizing the hour uh just
uh brief points uh just highlighting
some of the the prior concerns uh Peter
Brar representing Harvard Pilgrim
Healthcare the state's not for-profit
insurance carrier for the individual and
small group Market we certainly
understand the importance of emergency
ambulance transport and understand that
with an individual experiences an
emergency they really can't choose uh
which Ambulance Service uh responds uh
that being said we do have some concerns
with the bill some of which you've kind
of heard before already so I'll go
quickly uh certainly there's a cost
increase to this and as we've discussed
before uh you know that cost it doesn't
get eaten by some magic elf it's passed
on to somebody else basically people
paying the insurance premiums whether
it's the individuals or if they're
fortunate enough to work for a company
that pays for their insurance it gets
passed on to the the uh their employer
uh this is rate setting using an
arbitrary number it's the government
setting a number just they picked out of
the Hat um and uh setting the rate with
without getting rid of the balanced
billing uh it only affects the fully
insured Market what you saw is 10% of
these types of calls you're basically uh
this affects the people who are already
paying the most when the real problem is
the Medicare rates themselves are too
low uh and then finally there's nothing
really to incentivize providers to join
a network uh in fact it's an incentive
to other provider groups to say hey wait
a minute if we refuse to join the
network we can get the legislature to
set a rate for us uh that is just
arbitrary so for those reasons we think
this is a bad idea you've heard all
these reasons before I won't belor it
and keep you any longer from your dinner
thank
you thank you very much having no more